Vacation with your family?
Yeah,
we're going to Lanai.
Oh,
that'd be fun.
Yeah.
Boom.
And we're alive.
Speaking of vacations,
tell me about Guyana.
Yeah,
that's a good segue.
He'd been there a bunch,
you know,
I thought it was three.
No,
why was in.
I've been to Guyana twice,
but between there I went to Bolivia and
did like very similar,
very similar kind of trip,
like doing a river trip with
Amerindians.
Are those people weirded out by
Americans?
Because the Jonestown massacre thing.
It's so funny you bring up jealous town
because there's a couple things that
been like,
uh,
[inaudible].
So the,
the,
the main group I was with in Guyana,
um,
isn't the,
and I'll surprise one day when I was a,
they make a dish,
they make a dish with cassava,
which is a route like maniac.
Um,
they make a dish with that.
They make a flower from it and make a
dish.
And I was one day saying that,
hey,
that's a little.
It looks like pizza,
right?
No,
right,
right.
No comprehension.
But like,
no thought of what pizza is.
I remember thinking like,
wow man,
like something,
you take such a,
you know,
you just consider such a part of
everyday life.
It's good to know what it was.
Yeah.
And they don't know about Georgetown.
Whoa.
Even though was in their own country,
they don't know about it at all.
No,
it's just not.
But yet like what,
we'll get into this,
but you got to like realize sort of how
insular,
you know,
at the Amerindian communities are who
live in the,
in the jungle in Guyana,
the,
they have communication on any new yet
more and more now.
And there's a lot,
a lot changed.
The two times I went there with five or
six years apart,
they discovered sunglasses and I've
ever.
The first time I was down there trying
to turn them on because uh,
you know,
they,
they bow hunt for fish,
right?
Which one of the main ways they get
phished bow hunting for fish.
And when you're looking into the water,
polarized lenses are invaluable.
I feel lost without fish underwater.
And I kept saying,
man,
you got to get on board with polarized
sunglasses.
Not Hand in to.
And he,
he didn't like it,
this guy wrote and he didn't like
anything about having them on his face,
he just couldn't do it.
But then I go down to five years later
and um,
everyone of those boys is rocket
polarized glasses.
So you see changes.
But yeah,
that's the thing.
Like I've brought up Jonestown a number
of times because in the US,
if you say,
Hey,
I'm going to Guyana,
all anybody says don't drink the
Koolaid.
Right?
Really cool aid.
It was some like who late?
No,
it was a Koolaid type.
no.
So when people look at when we had this
conversation,
because there's a couple of things that
are important here.
What the poison was,
right?
So we had a conversation,
I looked back up the route,
I mentioned.
Sure.
That they make a sava.
Yeah.
So there's a root cassava and stuff.
So it's the route that gives all life.
They eat,
they call it.
No,
but I mean they eat fish and game.
Okay.
River fish and wild game.
And then that's like a staple the data
everyday.
And the other thing,
the everyday is a half dozen things all
produced from cassava,
which is kind of like a Yam and it's
cultivated with slash and burn
agriculture and they cultivate these
yams and from it they make a flower.
Um,
they make a type of grain.
It's like cous cous.
They make a syrup that's used as a
coloring agent in a flavoring agent.
They make a non alcoholic drink,
they make a somewhat alcoholic drink
that would be like an equivalent to
beer.
And then they make a much more alcoholic
drink,
which would be an equivalent like
fortified wine.
Wow.
They make all this stuff from this,
this route that they grow
in its raw form.
When you shred the root in squeeze the
shredding.
So it'd be like,
imagine you took a Yam and shredded a
yam and then squeeze the amd between
your hands and tripped out of liquid.
That liquid is deadly poisonous.
Okay.
Dogs,
chickens,
people,
anything that drinks that liquid dies.
Jesus.
And it's cyanide.
So the Jonestown massacre,
uh,
it was a cocktail of the best.
People think that it was koolaid flavor,
aid volume and potassium.
Cyanide,
my question coming home from Ghana was
like,
did they,
was the cyanide from the route where
they like doing homemade cyanide,
but,
and so when I got home I looked into
this and it's the,
and it seems as though that commune,
Jonestown commune had been ordering
actual potassium cyanide,
which is used in a number of mining
practices and other stuff.
So it's,
it's an available,
it's an available compound and dance.
They laced the Koolaid width.
I'd heard about this cassava stuff.
And what,
do they know what the process is like?
Did they know,
like how people figured out how to make
it non poisonous and help.
Wow.
It's just been done so long.
Yeah.
And the same stuff with like different
poisons they use to poison the that
people use to poison fish.
What strikes me about it is how in the
village,
like the,
the,
the Macusa village I was in,
um,
is mostly Macusa,
but there's also like Wapa Shoshana,
which is another tribe.
Carob is no our tribe,
but it's predominantly a Macusa village
and there's about 300 people with the
live in this village
and how careless they are with the
liquid.
Like if you nowadays like picture,
like you're like the type of person to
like you and me are married to and raise
kids with.
Right.
If you had that type of mom and you had
a big bowl of liquid that would kill you
if you drank a bit.
How that bowl would be monitored in your
household?
Jesus Christ,
that'd be like barbed wire around it.
Electrical fence and how do they sit?
Just Lazy.
They just lay it out and I said I was
asked.
This guy wrote them at him and I kept
returning to this.
There's certain things I can always ask
and it just like things that he
struggled to understand my fixation on
it,
but I kept saying to this Macusa Guy
Rove,
who I should back up too.
I got communication.
So guy out is.
It's the only English speaking country
in South America.
Everyone's got.
No,
no.
The,
the,
the government functions or English.
So if you,
if you picture yourself America,
it's northeast corner opening out onto
the southern Caribbean.
That's guy on,
it's bordered on the east by
[inaudible].
I'm on the West by Venezuela to the
south by Brazil.
It's 90 percent virgin rain forest and
within that 90 percent of virgin
rainforest is only 10 percent of the
population.
So the coastal people's are like creole
cultures.
People mostly descended from slave
trade.
Europeans in the interior are the
Amerindian groups and um,
the government functions sort of the
power in,
in Guyana is that as the coastal peoples
and there's not a ton of interest and it
used to be barely any interplay between
the Amerindian communities in the
government,
the government's English speaking.
So in,
you'll find that there's a lot of
English mixed in,
in the Amerindian communities in some
people like this Guy Rovan because he's
sort of a upping.
He,
he's like a,
he has a leadership role in his
community and he's learned just standard
English very well.
He's had a fascinating life.
Just how much stuff has changed for him.
Uh,
so I,
you can just converse.
Okay.
In a way that you can converse in like
an a type of the type of English we're
talking right now almost,
which creates this weird tension between
the things that you're discussing and
how you're discussing them.
Like for instance,
to have a guy just in conversational
English talking about problems they're
having with neighboring shamans in their
own shaman,
putting curses on each other and it like
creates like there's like a strange
tension between like how it's being
conveyed to you,
you know,
like how so like,
okay,
if you're talking conversational
English,
I guess like a life.
It's almost like you'd want it to be
when he's telling you this,
you'd almost want to be reading it in
like closed caption and he'd be saying
it in the indigenous language because it
sounds weird to have to,
to have an idea that's so foreign to us,
which would be like a battle of shamans
battling over access to wild animals.
Okay.
Um,
to have that delivered in conversational
English just struck me as unusual
because usually when you're traveling,
you're getting all of your information
like traveling and Bolivia.
A guy would tell a story and he'd tell a
story in,
um,
Tsimshian no one was saying that Shan
Chimani.
Okay.
He tells story in Chimani to a person
who spoke Spanish.
The person who speaks Spanish would tell
it to a person.
No,
no,
no.
Chimani guy telling someone who speaks
Spanish.
Then that person telling it
to a person who speaks Spanish and
English and then that person giving you
the information.
When you get it through that it takes on
a mythical quality.
Like you're crossing some space time
thing.
Right.
We're seeing like these ideas discussed
in their ancestral tongue.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you remember I sent you a video of a
guy talking about killing a Jaguar?
Yes.
Right.
The language you've never.
Like when he's speaking,
you're like,
I've never in all my travels,
I'd never heard of language.
It sounds anything like that is a video
online.
Can we play that?
It's online.
What was,
do you know the title of it?
It's a,
I think if you type in like,
um,
Chimani t,
s I Chimani Jaguar,
seatac.
See if Jamie can you pull it up?
It's very cool.
The language is really amazing.
Seem so ancient.
Yes.
It's not like has nothing to do with
like the Latin languages.
Just sound.
So it's very unique.
So I guess what I'm getting at is to
hear someone talking about something in
conversational English that seems so far
removed from just our understanding of
things.
It takes on a weird quality.
But what's nice about it is you can go
to a place where life is so vastly
different than anything we understand
and,
and just get like the straight dope
right from the source is why I love is
Kinda like what's so cool about Guyana
because you can go and converse with
people who are very much a hunter
gatherer culture today,
but just shoot the shit with them
without ever feeling like you're missing
something.
It's like the.
Everything's not lost in translation and
all weird and garbled and in like
painstaking to wade through.
But you can just ask like,
hey,
what's up with the local shyman?
I'll give you the dope on the Lord.
And so they trade spells.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
we'll talk about that.
But I,
I feel like I was laying the groundwork
for a,
the Jim Jones poison.
You find the video?
I thought I lost the word that you were
spelling.
T S I m a n e
t s I m a n e.
What does that mean?
Chimani.
That's how they spell it out.
Or they're being screwed up.
Yeah.
You spell a lot worse when you're not
actually writing it out.
Yeah,
I'm terrible.
I don't know how anybody wins a spelling
bee ever.
Toumani Tsi.
Yeah.
So if you type in Chimani Jaguar,
t s I m a n e Jaguar.
Wow.
The whole thing is an Amerindian hunter
remembers his best dog lost to a Jaguar
in the jungles of Bolivia.
Okay,
here we go.
Let's play this because it's fucking
awesome.
Here we go.
Following is an interview with a member
of the tribe of Bolivia.
Do their inherent difficulties of
translating indigenous languages.
Subtitles are at times approximate
income.
So he's explaining where he's
saying he hunts for food.
I always share that with my family.
I'm a good provider of me cutting up the
meat in this video.
I also enjoyed the adventure.
I love trekking through the jungle.
Once I was hunting with my favorite dog
and a couple of the dogs that ran ahead,
barking,
they were going after something you meet
kit you.
All of a sudden my favorite dog just
went completely silent.
There were about 50 meters ahead of me
and I got to the other dogs had gone
ahead after something
to hear.
Can You
keep
saying my favorite dogs laying there
dead.
There was a big homeless right side.
Almost looked like it had been arrowed
if we didn't get,
the first thing I did was pick up my dog
and said them where the ants wouldn't
get those body.
That dog was the bravest one I had.
I'm not going to translate information
that's just watching the video if you're
interested,
but you get a sense of how cool it is.
So the recover.
Do we fully cover the poison things?
No,
not really.
So I got home it yet,
so it wasn't the same poison,
but
Jim Jones,
uh,
he grew up in like,
he,
he was involved in a pentecostal church.
He's involved in the methodist church.
Then he kind of became a healer and
started his own cult.
It was funny.
I was reading about him when I was
trying to figure out the poison.
I was reading about how he was kind of
ahead of his time because the Jim Jones
massacre in 1979 and a 78 or 79 and one
thing to guide them sideways,
but with his church was that he wanted
to have an interracial service.
Wow.
And that caused friction in his church
at the time earlier in his career and he
moved out to the bay area and started
this church and then he got like kind of
paranoid and thought that his
congregants shouldn't be engaging in
sexual activities,
but he had,
he was syring illegitimate children left
and right.
They go down to Guyana,
go out to the jungle,
you know,
a thousand of them down there.
People in the US from the bay area kind
kinda like wondering what happened to
their loved.
They send a congressman down there to
try to figure out what's going on.
He shows up with a bunch of cameras.
The congressman says,
you know,
he's like,
I'm going to help anyone who wants to go
back to the bay area,
go back to the bay area.
He goes to the airstrip.
It was a shootout.
The congress,
the US congressmen gets killed in the
shootout and then data all start killing
themselves with the poison and firearms
and other shit.
Two hundred and 70 some kids over 900
people.
Yeah,
I remember.
It's like the defining thing,
but then yeah,
when you talk to these boys,
I'm like,
you know,
Georgetown,
like the Jonestown,
you know,
the Jim Jones,
Jonestown massacre and never drink the
Koolaid to like,
no.
See,
I had heard it was budget koolaid.
No,
that's the summit.
It was an I.
and that's a debate and in trying to
find like trying to like dig around and
find the source of the cyanide,
which became very important to me to
learn for some reason.
Um,
no,
I think Koolaid even tried to distance
himself from it was.
But they,
there's some archival stuff and I guess
in this archival stuff,
images like footage taken around and
photographs around,
people have found out that they had both
flavor aid and Koolaid on hand.
That's hilarious.
What it was.
Koolaid propaganda that's trying to pass
the buck on the flavor aid.
So yeah,
no,
no thing there.
And if you could.
So if you go up the main river that
drains the main river,
that drains guy on his elbow and if you
go way up the ESC,
Weebo and um,
you know,
you'll get to in a stream that comes in
from there called the roup annuity and
you go up the roof annuity and then you
get to the reward and at the mouth of
the [inaudible] in Rupa Nuni is real
village.
And in [inaudible] village you're a
isolated enough where you don't know
about 900 Americans and in some other
people from other areas night,
you know,
dying in a mass suicide.
Wow.
That's around the time you were born.
That's fascinating that it's why it
makes sense though,
that they're just so removed from it.
Know.
Do they,
um,
do they use agriculture,
like how are they getting this esop day
grow peppers and then they grow the
cassava and the cassava,
like it's kind of amazing.
Um,
you know,
we always hear about slash and burn
agriculture so they'll,
they'll go in and do a slash and burn in
the spot out in the jungle.
Um,
but it's like,
it's like a recycled sort of slash and
burn agriculture and I'll break down
what that means.
So they'll go into an area and slash
everything and burden just to clear the,
just so sunlight can make it through to
the ground.
So they chopped the jungle down and burn
everything.
Then the cassava,
like I said,
it looks like big yams when you grow it,
you just take a stock of an existing
plant
and just bury that stock in the ground.
It will sprout up a new crop and so you
know,
you're close to the equator so you don't
have seasons as much.
There's some seasonal variation.
They do have times that they do have
like they are wet season and dry season,
but it's like you always get about the
same amount of darkness as daylight and
they don't have the wild fluctuations
that we have in the temperate zone so
they can grow year round and they stage
it.
So you know you have a crop that's
coming in,
you have a crop that will become an in
three months.
You have a crop that will be coming in
six months.
You have a crop that becoming a nine
months and once you get a certain number
of cycles,
I can't remember how many cycles you get
off a piece of ground.
You let the ground go feral,
give it a few years and then come in and
burn it again.
Also intermittently,
every time you plant cassava,
you before you replant,
you make a little fire and burn some
debris in that same spot.
No irrigation.
You're not watering it at all.
Um,
and that's the only fertilize you're
giving it as you're burning some of the
surrounding just detritus scraped up
from the jungle floor that you burned
there and grow it.
And it is a staple of life that in river
fish and game,
it's just such a wild thing that it's
such a poisonous plant.
I don't get it.
There's all this stuff that there's
other poisons that are extracted.
I'm like people that,
people,
that people in South America and the
jungles,
people that use blow darts so people to
hunt with blowguns is generally
understood.
Like even talking to even talking to
them Macusa who hunt with bows and
arrows.
I asked them like,
why don't you guys hunt with blow darts?
Blowguns?
And he explained me,
we don't need to because we have
aeroplan,
which gives arrows.
Now if you were in this other area,
you know,
more up in the mountains and there's no
Arrow plant,
then you'd hunt with a blow dart.
So is aeroplan just to plant that makes
like a shaft,
like makes the Arrow what it,
what is it?
What is the type?
It's like a cane.
Well you know what it looks,
it looks,
it looks like a,
it looks like a palm.
And the palm leaf puts out these long
pieces in one.
One of those is ready you,
you caught it green and then they can
make an Arrow no time.
So you go out of the jungle,
find this piece and you're like,
like,
like you know,
like one of the theories on how we
domesticated plants species would be
that it was a very gradual,
unintentional domestication where you
would go out,
I'm going to just take something simple
like let's say a lot of raspberries.
Okay.
You go out and you gather raspberries
and you bring them home and you eat them
near home and then people are eating
these seeds and shitting these seeds out
and pretty soon there's a lot more grass
berries growing around your home village
just for the simple fact that you always
bring the seeds home and discarding them
around in,
in creating it so they have it except
for maniac,
which people don't even really.
I don't think it's really well
understood what it came from.
It's been domesticated for long time.
All the plants they use are widely
available in the jungle,
but tend to also have some around home
to that they've brought home and plant
in nearby or they just grow up there now
because they've been bringing this stuff
into their village for so long.
So aero plant is readily available.
Um,
they cut the Arrow shaft green and it
looks like just a green dial,
but it has some curvature to it.
Then no come home and they start a fire
and they heat the green thing just by
twirling it over.
The,
over the embers are over the flame
twirling it and getting it hot and it'll
let off a little steam.
And then you bend it in a neutral and
get a hot and bend it.
And you'll eventually make it,
well arrow straight.
Then the they make for different kinds
of arrows depending on what they're
hunting for.
So let's say you were making a arrow to
a,
it gives you more.
Let's say you're making a big game
arrow.
All right?
I'm in the big game they hoped would be
red brocket deer,
white lip packery,
which is a favorite,
um,
collared Peccary,
which we call have Alina and sometimes
tape here.
The,
the,
the air they use for that,
so they would take that.
So let's say they're going to build one
of those,
so they take that green shaft and
straighten it.
The next step is they find a wood called
bullet wood and they cut what would be
like a,
what's going to form the base of your
tip,
the base,
your spear and that bullet would,
they fit into the end of the green
shaft,
which is almost like a picture to having
the consistency of bamboo and they
shoved that bullet would nair and it
causes,
it forms like a base into that.
They take an old machete blade,
did they cut out and file down to be
about a four inch steel knife?
And that goes in to the bullet would to,
to the forms the junction between the
Arrow shaft and the steel piece.
That's the only man made material they
use in their arrows.
Then they take a plant that looks like
Jaco and they make their own string and
they got little bits of rubber from
rubber trees that they wax the string
with and they put a bullet would knock
in the part that that you're,
that you're bolstering actually pushes
on and that gets tied in to the Arrow
shaft and then they fletched Arrow with
feathers,
some Guan or black Curacao or crustless
Curacao and that's what they fletch
their arrows with because they have,
they're very water resistant.
So they're broad heads are made at a
machete.
Bleeds.
Yeah.
And this is a recent innovation for use
to use wood.
And how long have they been doing it
with machete bleeds in his lifetime,
it's always been.
They don't call them,
they come cutlasses enrollments,
lifetime robbins,
32.
He's a kind of my main friend down there
that hung out with both times.
I was down there in his lifetime.
He remembers people using.
He remembers people using blades,
which is made from like a bamboo,
like material.
So it'd be like a convex spearpoint cut
out of bamboo and sharpened.
He remembers people using those,
but he had always used cutlass blades.
Wow.
Now in Bolivia,
you'd see people who have,
who are just using the the old form.
There are other arrows when they make
arrows for hunting birds and they make
arrows for hunting fish.
The only man made material on those
arrows is hog wire fencing,
so basically wire fencing.
They snip out the hunks of wire,
smash it down till it's flat,
and then they can cut barbs and there to
hunt birds and hunt fish or the bowl is
this not a laminate boat,
so they make a bowl by just cutting a
tree,
single piece,
a single stem tree,
shaving it down to what they're after
and then take that same Yucca plant,
pull out the fibers out of the Yucca
strands and make bold strings.
That goes very quickly as well,
like we made a bolstering one day.
Wow.
Yeah.
You just,
they,
you take the strands and twisted like
imagine like you're rubbing your hands
to warm them up.
You got all those strands in your hands
and you roll them and it makes singles
and it makes strands that are comprised
of,
you know,
a dozen fibers.
Then you start braiding up from there
until you braid up a big long bow string
and that's how you string your boat.
So when they're shooting their bow,
like what's a long shot for them,
like 15,
20 yards,
long shot,
long shot and the length of shot you're
going to take sort of depends on um,
kind of depends on.
Well,
they don't really think like
the idea of the like that you're going
to wound it and it's going to get away.
Doesn't weigh on them very heavily.
Right?
Like in our culture and our hunting
culture here,
we've come to like really a,
the wound loss is something we do a lot
to avoid.
Okay.
There's a lot of talk where I don't,
you know,
you shouldn't be surprised to get a good
hit.
You should know what's going to happen.
Don't take shots that are too far away,
right?
We really put a strong value on,
um,
when you let the air or go,
or when you let the bullet go,
you damn sure know the,
you're going to have a quick clean kill.
At least we,
we put a lot of value on that in
practice.
Sometimes that stuff goes out the
window,
but anyone would say that that's your
goal.
I'm not on their mind.
You see them take some hail Mary's
right,
and they can shoot.
Like if you're,
if you're trying to shoot a bird,
all they're trying to do is get a
warrior point.
So one of those arrows I described
fitted with a long wire on the end,
cut out of a piece of steel fence with a
barb with a couple of barb's filed into
it and that head is joined by string to
the Arrow shaft so that once the head
makes contact,
the Arrow shaft can fall away.
But there's a string connecting the
arrowhead,
the wire barb to the Arrow shaft and
that allows the tangle up up in the
trees.
So when they shoot,
all they really need to do is pick that
thing with that wire.
Barb know that the bird or the hunt for
a large aquatic rodents,
knowing that the bird is going to get
tangled up in the trees overhead and
that they can then climb up to go get
it.
Even then,
I think even shooting like that kind of
thing where you're just trying to pick
the thing.
Thirty yards,
be very long.
Shoot and fish.
You're not shooting.
I mean shooting fish.
You're not really like bow fishing,
which I've done a lot of in my life.
A 10 yard boat.
Fishing shot is very far.
Yeah.
You're right above them,
right?
Yeah.
Because you're shooting down into the
water.
Now,
do they have,
do you have to judge when you're
shooting into the water,
you have to judge differently,
right?
The way diffraction.
Unless that thing,
unless that fishes sunning um,
unless that fish is stunning and it's
back at the surface of breaking the
surface,
uh,
you need to account for refraction.
So you're aiming way low.
Now if you've got a fish that's a fish
two feet below,
the water surface is extremely hard to
hit because it's so deep.
Your aim and like you're aiming at your
boot.
Well,
I mean it feels like that,
you know,
your aim and so there's a,
there's an equation so low you're aiming
way below the fish because refraction,
like anyone's ever taken a fishing pole
and stuck in the water.
Right,
right.
You see the hooks.
So that's like,
that's like the trick of both fishing.
But were they both fish for some of the
stuff?
My favorite thing that both fish down
there is also you also dealing with
current and they're,
again,
they're shooting a hollow arrow.
That doesn't weigh shit.
It doesn't cut through the water at all.
So they're holding way low for
refraction and holding way upstream
because their Arrow is so buoyant.
Oh Wow.
Now,
uh,
an American,
both fish and reg,
which I shoot has a fiberglass Arrow,
so the current isn't as much of an issue
because that arrows so heavy that it can
cut through the water.
But refraction is the same.
So that's why,
uh,
a point blank shot both phishing is
still very difficult and then you've got
to factor that.
You still need to hit the thing pretty
good in a place where the arrows is not
going to pop out.
There's a fish.
They bowhunt hunt for that they used the
bowl hunt for for salted fish called the
era [inaudible] and airplane was the
biggest freshwater fish in the world.
They say they're going to.
Sturgeon.
Yeah,
the largest freshwater fish.
The largest.
Okay.
The largest scaled.
An [inaudible] is the largest scaled
freshwater fish.
How big is it?
I mean,
they'll get him up into the hundreds of
pounds.
I've never even heard of it.
It looks like it.
It's,
it's a r a p A.
I am a.
yeah,
that's an Arab hyman.
She says,
Christ that looks completely
prehistoric.
They have a bizarre relationship with
these fish in the Macusa do in Guyana,
so that's amazing.
They used to hunt them looking creditor.
They used to hunt them to export the
salted meat based 100 to sell.
Assaulted me to markets.
Okay.
Now,
uh,
one of those is worth $7,000 to them
alive.
Holy Shit.
Because that's how much.
That's how much a white guy will pay to
catch one.
And let it go.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Oh,
so it's a guy like a guy will pay more
to Macusa,
will make more to take a guy out to
catch an error.
Piman let it go.
Then what you'd pay to hunt for elk in
the US on a guided trip.
Holy Shit.
They get seven grand to catch an error,
paella.
And when Rovan was a kid,
they would go on to week hunting trips
where they're gone for two weeks with
their father.
They would go for two weeks to hunt salt
fish.
So they were.
They were operating at a dug out canoes
that they would have to paddle and they
would paddle a duck that would make a
dug out canoe themselves,
paddle the Dugout,
can you up river for a week to get to
the good hunting and fishing grounds.
Then they would hunt and fish for one
week until they would get 100 pounds of
salted fish.
Then you'd go back down river,
which would take a day or two days and
then get to the mouth of the Rupa Nuni
River and paddle up the Reuben Nuni
river for two days to another town and
then they would haul the salt fish,
including era of flesh and sell that 100
pounds of salted fish for 75 US dollars.
So two weeks plus work for a family for
$75.
And now they will not touch those fish
because they make a handful of people
every year go down and give them seven
grand to catch one,
let it go.
So seven grand to them must be just an
enormous.
It's changed everything.
When I was talking about like that,
they discovered sunglasses and shit.
There's been a lot like they were
already onto this air pilot thing.
The first thing I went down and it's,
it's changed everything about it.
It's changed that village,
the air pilot fishery,
the way they used the arrows on them out
of trees,
they would.
So you're familiar like when,
when a river,
a river flows in asp pattern,
like repeating s's now.
And then,
um,
during high water,
a river will jump one of the assets.
You've picked it up saying yes.
So the river jumps and ass in it,
abandoned in the main channel abandons
the curves of the S.
okay.
Those curves become what's called oxbow
lakes were during high water during a
flood.
Those oxbow lakes are connected to the
main river system.
When the water goes low,
the oxbow lakes become a isolated air
pimas living those oxbow lakes and they
on peacock bass and other stuff.
So when the water got low and the era
pimas,
we're all kind of restricted to very
small little spots in the river.
They would climb up in trees overlooking
these places and wait for the air pilot
to come up near the surface and shoot it
with an arrow.
There was a detachable,
basically Harpoon head Arrow and shoot
it with the Arrow.
The Harpoon had,
would detach from the Arrow and the
Arrow would float on the surface
connected by string to the Arrow shaft.
You would then go take a hand line with
a hook and file that fish in your
dugout,
canoe until you could cast your hook out
and catch your Arrow and then you're
connected by your fishing line to your
Arrow and your arrows connected by the
tether to the Harpoon head and you would
hand line in and slaughter the Arab Ima,
Jesus,
and then drive the era.
Pama was salt and they and they still
have salt fish day,
like when we're out fishing,
they're salt and fish all the time.
They would salt that fish and then sell
it and then that became an endangered
like that became like a,
a very threatened species under the
thing and the I thing that they would
hunt for is would hunt for giant river
turtles and sell the meat and I'm
greatly depleted because their whole
lives occur on this one river in.
Once those market influences came in and
they had moved beyond subsistence
hunting and fishing and they moved into
market hunting and fishing.
They did the same thing that we did to
our own country in the late 18 hundreds,
early 19 hundreds is eight.
We're on course to entirely deplete the
resource through market demands because
their village gets more and more people
all time.
It grew considerably in the five or six
years between my two visits and their
environment just couldn't support that
level of market hunting.
So this era pimas thing,
chi is giving gives them a way to make
money to,
to buy staples and run a school and
stuff like that.
It gives them kind of an out.
And it's funny because like a,
I'm a lot more interested.
Like personally I'm a lot more
interested in a guy shooting fish,
arbitrary and salt in the meat than I am
a dude like me going down to catch an
error [inaudible] and let it go.
So in some ways it's sad.
Yeah,
it's sad just because like
it's not sad.
It's great that they're saving the
fishery,
but you see like just,
it's just sad to see shit changed man.
And why do they let it go?
Why don't they give it to the people
that live there so they could use it for
the meat.
They let it go so they can catch it
again because they want to make sure
that the population stays laughing.
So Robin,
what,
here's the thing,
the reason that one of those oxbow
lakes,
uh,
got lower and lower and lower and
someone,
one of their guys,
one of these Macusa guys realize there's
26 era piman stranded,
an oxbow lake and the pimas are running
out of water and when the water goes
down,
the air pine will excavate.
He'll keep excavating in the bottom to
even just save a little spot for
himself.
Okay?
And a guy found them in.
They're all in there,
but there's not enough water to,
to cover them up.
They can sip air is the thing that makes
them cooler.
So you can always find era [inaudible]
because they come up the gold bear,
Jesus,
the role air and very loud noise they
make when they come up to gold bear.
So they can live in low oxygen
environments.
Like if you took most fish and threw
them in a stagnant oxbow that's got six
inches of water in it,
I mean they're dead.
His Shit right?
Is there a pimas they can just keep
excavating a little spot in the bottom
and just wait,
praying or their equivalent of praying
that the water level comes back up and
liberate them from the oxbow?
There still needs a huge fish.
Yeah,
giants.
So they found 26 that were out of the
water in their backs were all messed up
from birds and other predators grab in
the air trying to grab the era pimas and
then they went and spent four days.
These are 26 air time is between 50
inches in upper eighties in length.
They spent four days moving these 26
Arab pimas into the river in a canoe
full of water.
Jesus Christ.
That's all valuable.
Those fish are to him now.
In the old days it had been dead.
His Shit.
Right?
Like you just sold them.
Yeah.
So they just like a fine night.
They have like on the river,
the river that they call home the river,
they kind of control.
There's like a finite resource.
But the thing is other groups,
so they're mostly [inaudible].
And my friend Roman's Macusa.
Um,
his wife is Wapa Shauna.
And there are other Wapa Shauna's and
other places who will come down to hunt
their area and they have very different
like these other groups that come in
have different hunting practices.
Like Robin was telling me one time that
he was going up.
So the largest snake in the worlds of
Green Anaconda,
their river has the largest thing in the
alligator family,
which is the black Caiman.
Some people say,
oh,
it's not a true alligator,
but the largest member of that.
How big is Emilia?
Black Caiman.
Yeah.
They get big.
They get bigger,
like American alligator big like yeah,
they get giants.
Some black came and stayed.
There used to be a market for those.
They use the market hunt those for the
heights for bags,
boots and shit.
So they have the giant River Otter,
which is a river out or like way to go
up river otters go to 100 pounds.
They had the biggest snake,
the Green Anaconda.
They had the largest aquatic roden in
the world,
the largest freshwater scaled fish by
some definitions.
The largest eagle,
which is the Harpy Eagle.
The Philippine Eagle has a bigger wing
span,
but some like when you measured by
weight,
the Harpy from and then there's another
harpy that's a giant,
like the Papillon,
the Papa New Guinea heartbeat.
The heartbeat is that one that eats
sloths and monkeys.
Monkeys and shit.
Yeah.
Was amongst some bad.
We saw one really.
So I'd been down in Harpy country three
times.
I finally saw my first heartbeat.
Wow.
Yeah.
Just like suggestic,
just piercing,
kind of unforgettable.
I'm just the face on it to the male,
the male face.
You're looking at it.
It just is like a.
So it remind me the first time I saw
links or are you just looking at it and
it just.
So freakishly different than anything
you'd looked at like that harpies face.
So they had that.
Um.
Oh.
So he's going up the river.
He's telling me this story,
how the whopper,
Shawna will come down and hunting and
hunting different than the Macusa.
Like the Macoun aren't that big on
killing Tay peers.
But the WAPA Shawna will come down in
their area and he says they come down
with arrows and got 12 inch steel tips
on him and he's like,
you know,
those boys are Hunton tape tapirs.
But he said one time he was going up
river and he sees a Green Anaconda and
he goes to look in.
It's got a arrowhead stuck into it and
he said,
and I told my companion,
the whopper,
Sean are here,
and they go up the river low mit.
Of course they come to a whopper,
shawn at Camp [inaudible].
The walk was shot.
He said he's like talking about this
particular watershed as a lawyer,
but he's like this particular group of
Wapa Sean is it travel ahead of
Christmas?
Because he's there.
They're like,
they have animist,
you know,
mystical systems.
But they also.
It's also infused with a certain level
of Christianity.
So ahead of Christmas,
the Wapa Sean and will go on a couple
month long hunting trip to get food for
Christmas celebrations and they'll
travel overland and by river to come
down and hunt them Macusa river.
And when they come down,
they're there.
They're playing for keeps,
so they come down there hunting Arab.
Hi Emma.
Which these,
which the Rebbe Macusa do not,
uh,
they're hunting anacondas.
They own everything.
They eat the Anaconda.
Yeah.
They dry all that shit and the fat,
they like to render the fat down because
they feel that it is helpful for,
um,
they feel that it's helpful for
arthritis.
We pulled up on,
uh,
on,
we pulled up on an Anaconda one time
that was 13 or 14 feet long just sitting
on the bank.
You can walk up,
you can walk right up to it.
Robin was telling me,
um,
again,
a type like mysticism and when we have
our own beliefs that would seem absurd,
right?
To an outside perspective.
But he was telling me if I were to touch
that Anaconda with my boat,
it would die a very painful death if I
just laid my bowl him on it.
And about how long he says he thought
about it at about 45 minutes.
Just the belief they have.
If you touch it with a hunting bow,
it will die in 45 minutes.
But it's painful.
How bizarre.
No experts,
I asked about that a thousand times and
never got any more clarity on it.
Net.
I say,
can you touch it with a stick?
It doesn't matter.
Go ahead.
Touch it with a bolt will die.
So.
But yeah,
they don't eat it,
but he was telling me if you're really
hard up and have really bad arthritis,
you can take the fat from Anaconda and
help cure the arthritis.
How much fat is an Anaconda?
I don't know.
I never.
I never cut into one.
I've seen a rattlesnake skinned.
They seem like they don't have any fat.
You gotta understand how big these
things are though.
They're so big.
I mean way bigger than your leg.
Yeah.
Was 14 feet long.
Fourteen feet long was probably weighs
hundreds of pounds,
right?
Oh yeah.
No,
hundreds of pounds if you eaten
rattlesnake.
Yeah,
it's not bad,
right?
It's not really.
Says that sucker.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a good one.
Jesus.
Yeah,
that's a heavy fucker.
those guys struggling for dudes
struggling.
Oh,
that's out a guy on.
Did you ever see that movie with
Jennifer Lopez?
Nope.
Anaconda.
So giant one like.
Yeah.
So that's the biggest snake.
And uh,
they'll eat cayman's anacondas well,
yeah.
Yeah.
And it came as lead them when they're
younger.
Yeah.
Know it's a vicious amount of everything
you eat and everything.
Um,
so these,
these gentlemen,
the Macoun,
she came down the Wapa shop,
Ashana have different hunting practices
and different things that are acceptable
to eat and they have.
And this is a group of Wapa Shauna.
So the hunting and fishing socks are
going after each other.
No,
that was a different story.
Now it's different pissing match with
someone else.
So,
um,
so there was that.
They're hunting area sucks that this
group of Wapa Shannon that come down to
rape and pillage on the Rebbe A.
Yeah.
Robin,
explain to me their hunting areas of
Piss,
poor hunting area.
So why do they stay there?
I don't know.
I don't know why they stay there.
Hmm.
Um,
and I asked him to like,
does it go,
does it make you guys mad today?
Come down because now the,
like the people in the predominantly
Macusa reba village,
um,
is onto a,
they're on like a pretty progressive
conservation program.
Like they can just dig through their
market hunting practices.
They got a glimpse into the future and
didn't like what they saw and they were
on a pretty aggressive program about
sustainability.
I'm their eyes toward the future.
The WAPA Shawna are this group of
Robuchon or not.
And when I asked them,
does it piss you off to the whopper?
Shauna come down here and oh,
they also the whopper,
Sean offish with poison Macusa.
Don't fish the poison.
Do they use the poison from the cassava?
No,
they a poison.
They use a,
uh,
there's a root and the leaf that are
both poisons the root.
It's an thing use here in the United
States when they have to do a fish kill.
Like if you get a big population of
invasive fish in a waterway and you just
need to like wipe the whole thing,
clean Ed's shit like that when you're
trying to do a fish kill.
We in the US use a thing called
[inaudible] and it's derived from a
South American plant.
And then there's another plant called
Barbato.
Well,
some people,
some,
you know,
it's like different people in different
areas.
And the Amazon drainage as a thing they
call Barb Bosco,
and that is a leaf that you just pull up
and it would look like you're just like
taken.
If you just imagine if you took a bunch
of time or rosemary and put it in a
mortar and pestle and pulped it,
and then you take and spread that in the
water.
That'll kill fish.
Both of,
I think they kind of,
they act in two separate ways.
There's two types of fish,
poise and one inhibits the fishes
ability to pull oxygen from the water.
So I watched them apply this poison and
you need to get area.
There's not much current because it'll
just wash the poison away.
So you get into one of these oxbow
lakes,
apply the poison kickback 20 minutes and
pretty soon all the Fisher up gulping at
the surface and then you shoot them with
bows and arrows.
Wow.
Um,
what's the other way of doing it?
And wrote none.
And I can't remember which category
wrote downfalls and,
but there's another one that has some
kind of like some kind of neuro effect
that it has some kind of brain in
somehow impairs some other aspect of
their body.
But these fish poisons are classed in
two categories.
I'm sorry,
I'm not more clear on what the two are,
but I know that the ones that just
prevent it from be able to get air and
the other one keeps the police in them.
The ones that don't suffocate them,
does that come up when they eat it?
No,
but they were telling me that,
that um,
if you need to watch your,
if you're poisoning a pond,
you need to watch it and make sure dogs
or any livestock don't come down.
It doesn't last long.
And they were telling me usually the
fish you don't shoot will recover if
there's some amount of water flowing
through it.
So they might go in and build a
temporary dam to block whatever inlet.
Let's just say it's a,
it's a isolated channel off to the side
of river.
They'll go in and pretty carefully with
rocks and logs,
block the flow,
coming into it,
poison it,
and then once they've gotten whatever
they want,
they unblock it and let the clean water
come in and they'll resuscitate the
fish.
Whoa.
But yeah,
if,
if they said of livestock dogs,
people drink that water can kill that.
It can kill that company.
Do they lose people?
Every unit that Kusamba water man and
talking to me,
you realize they lose this like a
handful of things that people get lost
too.
Um,
they had mentioned people dying from
anacondas.
They'd mentioned people dying from Black
Cayman's.
Um,
I know that injuries from puranas are
common snake bite.
The snakes are everywhere.
Like in one of these,
I remember sitting in Robin's friend's
house,
his outdoor,
like a Palapa kind of house,
you know,
with hammock strung in it and they're
just being a giant tranche.
Low like a two and a half inch diameter
transla.
And I'm not even doing anything to it.
Which randall is,
they just hurt.
Yeah,
they hurt.
They don't really fuck you up like a
black widow or something along those
lines before we found a kid who had been
hit by a scorpion young kid and um,
some scorpions can be fatal.
He was vomiting,
he was very sick,
but just the fact of life.
So when they get bit by snakes,
they getting bit by poisonous snakes.
Yeah.
There's one,
I think the most debt,
the deadliest snake in the western
hemisphere,
the coral they have.
Yeah.
They have all the ones he mentioned,
their chief getting hit by a,
by a venomous snake and them having to
call a medevac which is not in the air
for I think the air force came in with a
helicopter and got them out of there and
he was fine.
Wow.
Just the fact that law,
that shit's everywhere man,
but they got an eye for it and you don't
like,
like you're like,
you guys,
you know the,
the non locals eyes,
the one getting stung and bit and shit.
Yeah.
I can only imagine like the first time I
was down there I got hit by an electric
eel a couple times.
Right.
That scared the shit out of me,
but it's like you don't even know what's
happening.
You're in the water and Austin,
you're kind of getting electrocuted.
There was more in tune with all that
stuff.
That's a strong blast.
Yeah,
it hurts.
We have those on fear factor or grab
them.
It's like grab a barbell.
It's like grabbing a hot wire.
It's amazing that an animal,
a living thing and generate that kind
of.
Did it voluntarily for a joke just to
see what it's like.
Yeah.
It's not fun.
No,
I was shocked.
That sounds like it's probably just
annoying.
But I reached in and grabbed it.
I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
that's legit.
And it's like,
it's like grabbing a,
a hot wire fence with cattle in it.
Yeah.
I watched,
um,
there was some sort of a nature
documentary where something tried to eat
it and uh,
the electrical eel zapped it and you see
this animal just lock up and fall over
sideways.
Oh really?
Yeah,
just pedaled.
just,
just completely electrocuted it got it
to the point where it just couldn't
stand up.
Have you.
I know you'd like a.
you'll pull up some stuff.
Have you seen the video of the Jaguar
killing the Cayman?
Yes,
I've seen a bunch of fat solid shit.
Right,
because you just.
Since he's done that,
a thousand dollars.
There's A.
There's quite a few of them online.
And here's what's.
What's fascinating.
What does this cayman with electric eel
and alligator and electric eels.
Oh,
wow.
Frying.
Yeah,
it's just cooking.
Oh Wow.
No,
that's the.
Oh,
you asked about eating snakes.
Electric eel meat is not good.
That's one of the many things that the.
That's one of the many things that
Macusa like do not eat.
Look at his body.
Just twitching.
God,
that's amazing.
And obviously that's a little alligator,
but still.
Boy,
what a crazy animal.
Yeah.
Was brutal.
I never saw anything about Jaguars
killing Cayman's until about three or
four years ago.
And then there's like a whole slew of
these videos coming out.
It makes you wonder,
I guess maybe the advent of Gopros and
all these different video cameras.
People take down there and finally
started catching it on film.
Yup.
We missed the cycling bike.
We miss the sighting,
narrowly missed the siding.
We were down there,
tracks are everywhere,
so particularly because the time was
just down there.
Now the giant river turtles are nesting,
so they just like how we have,
you know,
just how you picked your sea turtles,
crawl up onto a sandy beach and dig a
hole that night later eggs and then
retreat back into the ocean.
Giant river turtles lay like that.
But so the sandbars are covered in
Boston turtle shells and there are
vultures.
So like black vultures and king vultures
and Cara Cara's around the sandbars
feeding on turtle eggs and Jaguar tracks
all over because the jaguars come down
to wait for the turtles to come up.
Wow.
So you've seen a lot of that and one of
the more surreal,
that's a perspective shot,
but,
but they're pretty big,
right?
Big with.
That's,
that's the oceanic.
That's not a judgment to look at that
sucker.
So how old is that fucker?
But I have no idea.
God does.
They live hundreds of years,
right?
Yeah,
they're,
they're ancient thing.
Might've been around when Columbus was
around the,
you know,
the,
the.
Are you familiar with the [inaudible]
treaty?
So,
uh,
things that band international wildlife
traffic,
they have.
There's a couple of turtles at the
MACUSA eat 'em.
They traditionally eight giant river
turtles and many people still do,
but they call that one the site.
He's turtle.
Oh Wow.
Because they now know they can't traffic
and there's certainly more so they got
like the eating turtle and the turtle.
But an image it will be forever burned
in my mind.
There's two things that this to like
sites that'll ever forever be stuck in
my mind.
And one of them is a,
a Wapa,
a woman
in a Dka,
Dka n y t shirt
up to her armpit and a riverbank digging
out.
One hundred and 50 turtle eggs.
Giant river turtle turtle eggs,
putting them in a handmade woven basket.
Wow.
Because you know,
like Khloe,
like donated clothes,
like cast off,
close wind up,
you know,
getting bundled.
So you see people with like crazy
American tee shirts and stuff on where
like I have like a Bob's pizza,
Santa Cruz,
California or whatever,
you know,
and it's just like something sent down
there through goodwill,
donation centers,
whatever.
So they'll have like um,
like brands,
you know,
like,
like famous brands that you see like
people,
you know,
in our,
in our culture wearing,
but there'll be like hunting monkeys in
them
and like the laggers thing,
it creates that kind of tension,
you know.
So do they recognize the city's like
regulations?
Do they,
did they not eat those turtles?
Yeah.
So
you gathered is kind of loose.
They don't traffic in them but they will
eat them,
but they will eat them.
Yeah.
So they will collect the eggs but they
won't kill the turtles to sell.
So as they become more aware of
conservation,
like with this giant fish was the fish
again,
the Arrow piman as they become more
aware of conservation to do.
Do you see them,
like recognizing like,
hey,
there's some stuff that we have to leave
alone.
We got to let it recover.
I mean,
they,
they obviously,
they're aware of the cycle of life when
it comes to their slash and burn
agriculture and leaving spots alone,
like are they becoming more aware of
like what animals they've kind of pushed
to the brink of extinction.
Yeah.
And it's like I don't even know how,
which is coming from the younger
generation because talking to guys,
to our new guy who's I'm 43,
this guy just a couple of years older
than I am and talking to him.
Um,
and he was a market hunter.
He's glad to see what's happened because
he in his own lifetime saw how much they
had depleted everything.
So he and his lifetime salt,
like from market hunting,
not just from subsistence stuff,
but as that village because the village
was a handful of families right then and
now it's 305 people.
As that village grew,
he watched,
um,
the giant river otters.
They were hunting giant river otters to
sell the hides into Brazil and they
would smoke them out of their dens.
So he watched their numbers go down as a
100 pound otter.
Yeah.
Wow.
For convenience.
Just as the name would let you know,
and very vocal,
a large vocabulary of crazy sounds.
The giant river otters make they get
when they see you,
they're pissed and they start making
crazy noises.
See them.
Oh yeah.
You see them all the time.
They're squawking at you.
Like,
what does it sound like?
It's like a
like,
wow.
But a lot better now.
Look at that soccer.
Oh,
they're easy.
And some kind of snake or eel.
Wow.
Yeah.
They make,
they have an alarm noise in a number of
barks and crazy sounds.
Uh,
so he watched those get depleted from
Hyde hunting,
giant river turtles from hunting eggs.
He said he could see that the era pimas
were disappearing.
And so he was really glad this guy was
really glad that they'd gotten onto some
other way to bring some cash into the
village.
Wow.
And the air uptime of fishing,
how do they find out about this?
Like people from the United States are
like,
where are they coming from?
You know,
I'm not sure.
I know that there's been a number of
companies,
um,
coasta sunglasses,
company Kosta invested pretty heavily
through a conservation program.
They have coasta sunglasses invested
pretty heavily in helping them establish
a guiding system down there to take
people out to fish Arab.
So these people that come down,
trained some of the Macugen how does
deal with Westerners,
like for instance,
um,
in the time and we were out,
we were out.
When I'm with them on the river,
we're out.
I'm with them
participating in the hunting and fishing
activities that they do year round on
the things that they identify to be
sustainable resources because they
still,
like,
they still hunt several days a week,
right?
Rovan that they live off fishing game.
Everyone in that village,
all their protein is hunting and fishing
protein and some chickens that they
raise,
but that's all their protein.
So they're engaged in,
in a daily sense.
Like Robin says,
he spends about two days a week farming.
He spent two or three days a week
hunting and fishing.
And then he has other obligations yet is
to take care of,
but he hunts and fishes constantly year
round and it's just,
if he kills a white lip packery he says,
that's good for a week.
Did you bring your bow?
Yeah,
I brought my bowl fish and boat and I
brought a regular bowl.
Now when they saw your bow,
where they're like,
Jesus,
can you get us some of these,
you know,
surprisingly not that excited about it
because they,
I think that they know they would run up
against sourcing problems with the
arrowverse got a,
at one point in time,
robin had a recurve,
um,
but he lost his house burnt down and he
lost his recurve anyways.
So just for the simple fact that you can
make them and make arrows very quickly.
They don't need to worry about how you
ever sourced parts.
But,
but they have all this other stuff like
machete blades and all these different
things.
It seems like they would.
I mean,
if you get a good compound boat,
Jesus Christ,
I think if you brought one down and left
it there,
there,
I would get a lot of use will under.
Absolutely.
Would it be too effective?
Like would they run into problems with,
you know,
like they have kind of a sustainability
issue,
right?
I'll say.
Yeah,
I think that if you went down,
um,
this is speculation.
I would think if you went down and gave
it,
if you had down with a dozen of these
things and left them there,
I think that along that river corridor
you would see a diminishment of a
handful of bird species for sure.
Yeah.
I would think because the birds.
But here's the thing,
here's why it's a little bit tricky
because I think that you would also be
reducing demand because one of the
things about the birds,
the Guano and curtis owls is that they
want them to fletch arrows,
but they're hard to get.
So they really want them because they
liked the,
they classify them under this broad
category that you hear in other places
called police and basically it's like a
term,
some people say Paul always refers to a
specific career,
but some people use pulleys like,
like,
uh,
like Turkey,
like bird,
like a Turkey being a good edible birds.
So the birds that they fletch arrows
with are also coveted food items.
All right.
I would,
I feel that,
yeah,
if you were to bring conventional
archery tackle in,
you would see that diminished.
Now other people will have shotguns,
but the limiting factor there is how
expensive the ammunition is.
So they'll have like the shotgun shell
or they might have a handful of shotgun
shells that would last them a long time
because it would own use when absolutely
necessary.
Like the Villa David,
they've been having a Jaguar problem
when we were there.
They had over the previous two months,
last 24 dogs including a dog while we
were there to a Jaguar who comes in at
night and kills dogs and chickens.
He was speculating that at some point in
time they will probably have to get rid
of that Jaguar and that it would be a
firearm issue there would have to like
figure out a solution for with a
firearm.
So even people that might have a
firearm,
I'm have limited ammunition and it's
sort of a,
a,
a league,
a tricky spot and the legal situation
for them to have a firearm.
But Bose I think that they would knock
the shit out of carousels and Guano if
they had good bose but then might not
want them as heavily because it didn't
need the fletching for fishing.
I think they're tackle superior close to
superior for bow fishing.
Why is that?
Because the shots are so close,
it just isn't really necessary.
Like it's like it's not,
it's just not necessary to have that
kind of investment and you just tend to
lose arrows,
bow fishing.
So it wouldn't make sense to have very
expensive fiberglass arrows when you can
make an Arrow and 15 minutes,
20 minutes.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
And then you're still limited to very
close range shots.
Um,
the,
like when I was in Bolivia where they
hunt for a bigger variety of stuff,
including monkeys,
a bose would be a gay,
like,
like compound bows be a real game
changer on monkey hunting.
So they're not monkey hunting and they
won't touch them really that.
Here's the couple.
There's a couple of things that are
really hard to talk.
Earlier I was saying like,
you have this luxury of being able to
have good conversations in English and
get your aunts,
your questions answered,
right?
Some things you really,
uh,
you hit a wall.
Okay.
Now,
one of the things you hit a wall on is
if you say to someone like,
how many days out of the year would you
guess you do x?
It just like you never get there.
You never get there.
Did they not understand years now?
They do,
but it's just like,
because we speak in that way,
it's hard for me to understand why
that's such a hard question.
But you,
it would be very hard to get
satisfactory answers about how often do
you do something.
Another thing is like,
how much do you like?
Like do you like hunting or fishing more
isn't something that's thought about
because it'd be like,
I'll be like,
do you like to hunt more,
are far more?
You have to do both.
So it's not like the luxury that we
have.
But what do you like?
But I don't have to do both.
You can't do one,
but he was telling you he hunts two days
a week.
He farms two days a week.
So we meet like asking the same question
a thousand times and finally kind of
getting finally kind of getting to a
spot because they couched it because one
time I pushed him and pushed and pushed
him.
How many days a year do you hunt and
fish and we've talked about this for
forever and he came up with the figure
maybe 200 or 250.
Then later I'm like,
how many days a week do you hunt and
fish.
And I asked them that a thousand times
and got to know if you do the math.
One of those numbers is wrong.
It's just not.
And it also like what you like most.
Do you like this most like that?
Most.
Another thing is why don't you eat x?
Right?
But if I think about it,
if imagine if someone came from another
country to here and you're driving them
around and every single thing they see
that's alive.
If they said to you,
why don't you eat that?
Right?
Why don't you eat that spider?
I don't know Bro.
We just don't eat those spiders.
Why don't you eat that cat?
That's a really complicated question.
Like,
uh,
we don't eat house cats.
Let me count the reasons why we don't
eat house cats,
you know,
so,
and I'm like,
why don't you eat monkeys?
He's not like,
oh,
silly.
We don't eat monkeys because it's just
like we just don't eat monkeys,
but they don't have any weird
relationship with monkeys,
right?
No,
none.
The more I press them on it,
it wound up being he would say,
because we have so many fish and they're
so easy to get a bite.
You hunt white lip peccary now white lip
peccary for folks who don't know.
And He.
Does that look like a Havalina as well?
Yeah.
So it's a little bigger than handling
the main difference from,
from a human,
a human perspective.
Looking on the to what you would.
What you would jump at is the gregarious
nature of the white lip peccary.
So there's three peccaries,
there's like the Cohen,
I think the Chaco and Peccary,
which I've never laid eyes on,
White Lipson and collared and the
collared peccary a dozen is a giant
group of colored pack.
That's like a big ass group of collared
peccary.
And that's what we have in this sucker.
Yeah.
And that's what we have in west Texas,
Arizona,
parts of New Mexico,
right.
So it's essentially the same thing as a
humbling.
The collared peccary is the havoline.
Same exact thing.
The white lip peccary November,
I said like a dozen is a bunch of
collards.
Have Lean.
I've hunted those in the US and 700
those in Mexico.
White Pack.
We'll run in a group of 100 to 200 whoa.
And white lipped peccaries when I was
mentioning in cassava,
white lipped peccaries are hell on
cassava.
Patches.
They eat them.
They come and meet the stalks,
not the route.
They'll destroy the cassava patch and
they'll dig,
but they particularly liked eat this.
They'll come in and they like to eat.
The young shoots growing up.
Now,
can they eat the cassava the route or is
it poisonous to them?
Don't know.
I don't know.
Huh?
That's a good question.
I'll wish I would've asked that.
I would.
If I had a week,
I would get a satisfactory answer out of
that.
So the white lipped peccaries will come
into the village and raise holy hell.
Everyone running grabs their bows and
then they start shooting in the nail,
chase them into the jungle and maybe
even track them for a day trying to
whittle away at them because it's a
great meat.
It's like the favorite game meat is
white lip packery.
They like it better than collared
peccary because they're bigger,
but is it like a pork or something like
that where they had like scent glands,
so they're very.
Yeah,
looks like pork has a very strong off
putting.
The animal has a very strong offputting
smell,
but the meat doesn't know if you handle
it properly and keep it clean.
It's never.
It would never be regarded like as as
good as pork to the American palate,
but to the Macusa Palette,
it's the best,
so their whole thing that we don't want
all these animals,
various animals,
because you have so many fish,
flies out the window with white lip
peccary,
but a lot of the white lipped peccary
hunting is also related to the
protecting of crops.
Now as long as Rovan can remember,
real village has had a group of white
lipped peccaries that would come through
the area trying to raid the gardens and
when it came to the area raiding the
gardens,
they would kill some number of them and
then they would track them into the
jungle and stick with them and kill a
handful.
And it was when that happened was a very
good thing.
They liked the peccaries.
There's been a number of years where no
packer,
where something happened to this group
of one or 200 peccaries they haven't for
years.
They have not been through the village.
It's not attrition because he was saying
at the most when we get,
when they come through and get us,
he would say on average we would get
actually kill between one and four when
they come in and hit the crops if we
stick with them and a group of guys goes
after me,
white killed between one and four and
there's 200 of them.
So it's like,
it's not like that.
Like slowly whittle away at them.
Right.
It just would never account for that.
But they vanished.
Robin never wanted to explain to me why
they vanished,
but if I kept pestering him about it and
eventually he told me,
here's the deal.
Since [inaudible] villages now so
wealthy and we have so much food,
other groups and other villages have
grown very jealous of us
and he told me that a shaman in another
village got so insanely jealous of
[inaudible] prosperity through fishing
for [inaudible] and through all the good
hunting and fishing that they have
there,
that he got so jealous that he.
I'm locked up,
that this shaman locked up there
peccaries.
He doesn't know where perhaps in the
mountains they're locked up.
Now
getting them out is getting them
unlocked is difficult because at the
time that this shaman locked up there
peccaries,
they happened to be without a good
showman in their village that they have
a bad shot when they have a shaman in
training his,
his.
He is a young sham and in training and
his powers are slow to develop.
So what happened to the old guy,
Donald?
This guy's powers have been slow to
develop.
He's getting there and soon he will
hopefully be in a position to unlock the
packer.
Now what's a young showman?
Is it like a young president?
Like I didn't mean.
Oh,
does it really?
Like we brought up wanting to go talk to
him.
I got the sense that that wasn't the
best idea to go visit with him.
Really?
Yeah,
to like 300 people in the village.
Three hundred and five.
Wow.
Got It.
And I brought up a number of times.
Just got the sense that it wasn't the
greatest idea to go talk to.
So is there,
theatrical involves this guy like living
on the outskirts of town and he was in
town but no claims mystery.
So here's a handful of things that was
like,
Roman was telling me and in it,
and I want to say,
man,
I do not like if I'm here.
Okay.
If you told me something that I thought
was outlandish,
I would fucking jump on you.
Right.
And I'd be like,
that's ridiculous right now.
That desire to like be right and to
dispel a wrongness like I don't have a
lick of that shit when I'm talking to
these guys.
Right,
right.
I've never like,
wow,
I don't buy that.
Right.
It's just like it's so inappropriate.
Feeling.
Right.
And it's so interesting to me and also
give such an interesting glimpse into
how most cultures and societies were
structured
long time in pre Christian Times.
Right.
That it's just like,
it's just educational.
So I'm not in any way.
I'm never saying like,
wow,
I don't buy that.
I'm just saying like,
oh,
okay.
Right.
That's great.
Thanks for sharing.
So magic.
Yeah.
So I'm not in any way I,
I've never like,
here's some things that were explained
to me.
If you're having a problem or you're,
your archery skills go downhill,
like you have a few misses the way to
correct that would be to go up and take
the hand,
hold the bowstring and punch a beehive
and then hold your hand up to that hive
because they don't miss
and you will find you will.
They will demonstrate their accuracy
when they bombard you.
And Robin was saying that most of them
even know to hit you between your
fingers where it really hurts.
You will then absorb
that accuracy in your hand and you will
do a lot better shooting.
Huh?
And the more you can do this throughout
your life,
the strong group will make you.
It's also helpful just even with kids is
also helpful to beat him by like a
bullet ant for instance.
Um,
I had the hat and before,
and it's awful,
but to get hit by a bullet ant to absorb
some of the ant strength,
but this sharman that fucked up there.
Peccaries could also just be jealous of
you.
And,
and strip your ability to shoot
accurately.
And what I want to point out that robin
has an email address.
Right?
Wow.
Yeah.
You can email.
I email with them.
Wow.
And he's firm in his beliefs but also
also.
Yeah.
But there's also a rational.
It's,
he seems fairly rational outside of
this.
Listen,
it's like I'm torn even talking about it
because like I don't want it.
I'm sort of talking about it because,
because I have such a love for him as a
person,
uh,
that I wouldn't want to say that would
make,
that would like dispel that idea of like
did,
did he did.
He's not like that.
He's not perfectly rational.
Like I would go anywhere with this guy
extremely capable.
But you're talking about
just like some,
some long held beliefs.
So it's their cultural belief systems
are just deeply ingrained and there's
probably some sort of a placebo effect
attached to all this.
They've seen it in effect,
someone has cast what is a,
there's a,
some point in time those,
those packers are going to come back
into town.
Yeah.
And then what were credit fall?
They'll probably say the Shaman has
relaxed grip.
Awesome.
The new sholman yeah.
Or if someone wants credit,
it's just a way of explaining the
volatility.
Here's the other thing.
Here's the other thing,
like,
you know,
you could go,
well,
let me give you example.
I'm going to make a point about the way,
um,
to sort of see a culture in transition,
right?
Because it's always so relative.
But,
uh,
the,
there's a writer as a staff writer at
the New Yorker or one of my favorite
journalists of all time.
John Lee Anderson.
You might be familiar this book,
Jay,
like he wrote sort of the definitive Che
Guevara Book,
Che.
Um,
he's a war correspondent rights troubled
spots around the country around the
world.
John Lee Anderson,
he wrote a piece not long ago in the New
Yorker about a group of people that
were,
had just made that we're,
we're making first contact with the
outside world.
Just recently,
2015.
They had been.
They were regard.
They were initially regarded as an
uncontacted group that lived in the
border between Peru and Brazil in the
jungle.
And for whatever reason,
they started coming out to a main river
where they were having some contact with
other groups and they killed a couple
people,
bose.
So the government was in a situation of
when dealing with a first contact group,
you can't go in and just start putting
people on trial and shit.
Like it only leads to more problems.
So they were trying to.
It's an article about the difficulties
of leading,
of introducing a first contact people's
into sort of a constructive engagement
with the outside world.
I'm a trick there is some people look
and they have some countries have a
policy of isolation for uncontacted
people and try to enforce isolation.
Other theorists on this or other
anthropologists think that's completely
unfair.
That is the most human of tendencies is
to find other humans and swap ideas with
them.
Right.
It's like it's you.
It would be laughable that I would come
to you and say,
Joe,
I'd like to prevent you from meeting the
French.
Less.
Some aspects of Frenchness rub off on,
you know,
they're worried about other things too,
but they're worried about like disease
and stuff.
But also a tendency to to the alcohol
can be destructive,
being lured into prostitution,
all forms of exploitation,
trying to protect people from this.
Then there are also the romance of
running into these uncontacted tribes as
such that some people.
Yeah,
so some people say those photos that
they took from the helicopter where they
see these people are covered in war
paint.
They're pointing arrows at the
helicopter.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
And that's the shit that I'm guilty of,
right?
Because even though that's what I was
going to lead up,
this thing where this battle I have in
my own mind,
right.
That even though,
I mean they are far,
far away there,
you know,
far,
far removed from a first contact people.
They're not even,
like I said,
the guy's got an email address.
I'm not trying to paint this as
something is not right.
But at the same time they made their
bows from raw material out in the jungle
and hunt and fish for all their protein.
I love that shit so much and I like
laying in bed.
If you told me you can never go back.
I want to lay in bed thinking about that
occurring,
right?
I want to lay in bed thinking about a
guy having a problem with this shaman
because it's just so refreshing and
like,
like mentally exhilarating.
So does know that that's going on.
So you get caught in this kind of a,
you get caught in this kind of.
It's almost like the opposite.
It's like the opposite of colonialism or
something where you get caught this
thing of wine to be like,
oh these precious cute people.
If I could just keep them like how I
like them,
where they stirred my imagination.
Yeah.
You know,
I just want them to stay like how they
are because that's how I like them.
Like when I come down to visit,
I like to know that they're all doing
the shit that's interesting to me,
but they're in no way are they
perceiving their experience
in that way,
but you go down and see like in the
handful of years as much they change all
the time.
Right.
And the handful of years to see that,
just like practices are different,
dress is different.
Clothing.
Very different.
So you're just seeing it happen,
you're seeing in real time,
it happened in a fast way.
Now you might come up and be like,
oh,
and I was in the US and the pre internet
days and I came to the US and the post
Internet days and um,
it man is that place different,
but you're watching it like wherever you
live,
you're also seeing that happen too.
So you're living that transition.
But to go to there and then come back
five years later,
uh,
and see things different.
It really,
um,
yeah man,
it fucking,
as much as I hate to admit it and is a
wrong is it is.
But just to be like absolutely up,
but like a kind of bummed me out.
So when you talk about,
when you saw it from a hunting
perspective,
because I tend to view the world through
a hunting and fishing perspective.
When you talk about bringing bows down,
my first thought is,
oh,
that's no fun.
They shouldn't do that because I like
watching them a lot with the homemade
boats right now it's,
it's totally rational and it completely
makes sense.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's
furness Dahlia,
and then you find it,
you find it as it's changing,
you know,
as much as you know about the American
West as much as you told me about the
history of the American west and the
native Americans to see these people
that are essentially like in some ways
like the native Americans before the
colonial people arrive.
Yeah.
Or like a,
I guess it would be,
this is a bold statement.
If there's an anthropologist or a
historian listening,
they're going to pull their hair out,
but it would,
maybe it would be like I'm so hesitant
to even throw this out.
Just it's extremely approximate and full
of holes and full of contradictions,
but some kind of post contact scenario
and I don't know,
like let's say it was the 18 nineties or
something right here.
The firearm was very much a part of
stuff,
you know.
But yeah.
Um,
but you know,
it's,
it's makes,
it's complicated in the Internet age,
but at that time you definitely,
we definitely established a form of
terrorism in the American West right
there by the,
you know,
I mean,
well,
before the Francis Parkman France
department was this figure,
he wrote the definitive history of the
French and Indian war.
But in 18,
42,
he was a historian.
He had health problems in 18,
42,
he did a tourism trip out on to the
great plains.
He met some fur trappers,
some mountain men.
He traveled with the Oglala Sioux,
a crazy horse who probably wasn't crazy
horse yet.
He was his name curly as a kid.
Crazy horse.
He was in crazy or like the three
stooges,
I think that,
I think that was like a name for mount,
you know,
and have no idea what it meant before he
adopted the name crazy horse.
Um,
he would have been 13 years old and
Francis partment traveled with them as a
tourist and they went into the black
hills of South Dakota.
They went in there to get lodge poles
because there was a time you were in
there,
go in and fit out their lodge poles for
their teepees to replace broken
lodgepoles.
They went up in the black hills,
killed some big horn sheep by throwing
rocks down on him,
off a cliff,
went and shot a bunch of buffalo and he
was out there like as a tourist,
so tourism in the American West.
Now you got to remember the last,
the last free roaming,
the last like non confined plains
Indians didn't get rounded up until,
depending on your definition of 18,
76,
18,
77,
so he was out there way before that.
There were still like what they
described at the time as hostile wild
Indians were running around and he was
traveling with them as a tourist.
So I just bring that up to bring this
idea that here's this group of people
who are very much engaged in terrorism.
Like I was down there.
I was down at because I wanted to go on
a river trip.
I walk in and it's something I've done a
handful of times.
I wanted to go on a river trip and and w
w and participate in their hunting and
fishing and food gathering activities as
they engage in them in the same way they
might engage in it if I wasn't there.
That's why we weren't fishing.
That's why we weren't catching air them
is letting them go.
So there's that in the Internet era,
but it's like there's that thing always
returned to.
It's like you're still,
you're still
hunting and fishing all your own food or
growing in your yard now.
When you guys went down there,
did you participate in the hunting and
fishing or did you just observe?
No.
Participate in it.
You participated with their traditional
tackle or did you use your own stuff?
Done?
Both.
I've hunted fish with my own and I've
hunted fish with their bow and in the
end I wound up the first time I went
down I hunted fish the second time too,
I hunted for fish.
So both fished with um,
their gear.
But then it always felt like somehow
funny too because like there's the thing
that happens when you're watching like
goofy,
you know,
watched like goofy survival shows and
shit.
Desire is the part where the host,
you know,
grapples with how difficult it is to
master ancient technologies.
But you're trying to just pick it up and
do it from scratch.
Okay.
Rovan has been shooting that bow at
four.
He's 32 years old.
He's been shooting that boat at fish for
let's say 27 years.
It is not an unusual thing to him.
Alright.
So when you go pick it up and be like,
man,
you got to give props to,
these guys should be able to kill a
fish.
This bowl.
It's like,
well kind of in kind of not.
Because if you spent 27 years doing
something,
you're damn sure going to be good at it.
The same way is if you took someone like
one of these first contact people's from
between Peru and Brazil and handed them
my laptop and said,
hey,
pull up my g mail contacts from scratch.
He might be like,
man,
I gotta give props to you guys.
Had no idea.
Right.
It's just like,
yeah.
So I was having this conversation with
someone the other day where,
you know,
the first time Daniel Boone in 17,
60,
Daniel Boone went to the cumberland gap
for the first time and dropped down into
what's now Tennessee and Kentucky and he
stayed there hunting hides.
He was a hide hunters.
They,
they're hunting heights for two years,
ran out of gunpowder,
made his own gunpowder and made it out
of a bat.
Guano your own piss pot ash,
right?
You can cook this shit up.
Right.
And make your own gunpowder.
And I was looking at as being the
epitome of woodsmanship and the fact
that he could do it makes him seem other
worldly.
How do they,
what kind of formula do they have for
how much piss?
How much bat?
Guano,
which just something they knew.
Do you know the bat?
Guano used to be something that was so
cherished.
People would go to war for it.
Yeah,
for explosive.
Fucking incredible.
Not just for explosive,
but also for fertilizer.
Oh,
no.
Yeah,
that's what the term batshit crazy like
the freezer bash.
People would fight for bat shit.
Yeah.
They would go nuts like it was so
valuable.
That's where all the buffalo bones went
after the near extermination of the
buffalo really.
But the really good shit was bone China,
China,
tableware and everything else is
fertilizer.
Wow.
Yeah.
You could make the same.
Some of the same characters that were
involved in the slaughter involved in
picking out the bones are called bone
pickers.
Picked up fertilizer.
But no,
I didn't know that about Baghwan have no
idea that bone China.
Yeah,
there's still bone China.
No kidding.
Yeah,
I thought China was always some sort of
ceramic.
There's a place in Detroit on the,
on the Rogue River in Detroit that have
the rouge river,
rogue river,
depending on what Dude Michigan you're
talking to.
Um,
there's a place there called the Detroit
carbon works that used to.
So when you're watching movies,
including the revenue,
you know,
that giant pyramid pile of buffalo
skulls that turns up in everywhere,
every book,
every movie.
That photo was taken at the Detroit
carbon works and what they are producing
was bone fertilizer.
Wow.
Is there more than one of those photos
everywhere?
Wow.
You can't escape that picture.
That's an incredible picture.
That's.
That's taken in Detroit,
Michigan,
where I'll point out was one of a
handful of states that never had buffalo
in the history in the history.
There's no buffalo,
Michigan,
so they're extra paid it out of
Michigan.
They just knows where those bones are
picked up in the American west ship by
rail to Minneapolis,
Chicago,
Detroit turned into bone fertilizer and
then shipped back out for people tilling
up the great plains.
Go back to that photo again.
The photo.
So disturbing.
Wow.
How many skulls is that?
In my book about Buffalo,
I'm describing that picture and I say
that the man standing on top is like an
exclamation point at the end of a long
sentence about death and destruction
because I can look at them.
It's like he somehow realizes the
weirdness of what he's involved in,
but that was post extermination.
There's a crazy,
um,
podcasts from Dan Carlin on the wrath of
the cons on the GIG economy.
They describe how the charisma and Shaw
sends a,
a group to a checkout Gin,
China,
and they got there like about a year
after getting,
his con had killed everyone in the
entire city,
over a million people and they thought
what they saw in the distance they
thought was a snow cap mountain.
As they got closer,
they realized it was a pile of human
bones.
Really.
Those guys are hardcore shit.
Yeah.
Jonestown,
what do you.
But then nothing but be like,
oh,
minor.
I was like,
it'd be like a car crash.
He changed the carbon footprint of the
human race.
Him during his time,
they don't know how many people they
have the population through deep
population cooking fires.
They,
they believe they killed more than 10
percent of the population,
like Gingiss Khan and his people through
his orders killed more than 10 percent
of the population of the world.
And wasn't he the number one
land conquer,
but just never held on anything.
Well,
conquered more in like conquered more
than Napoleon.
Conquered more than Hitler,
but just didn't hold it.
I'm not sure about that.
I don't know about that,
but I know that they always lived in
tents and they despised people that
lived in homes.
They thought they were pussies the
breath out after their life.
They brought out their vulnerable to
probably.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean,
is anybody listening a wrath of the
cons?
It's a five part series and I think Dan
Carlin,
he charges for them.
You can buy it on Itunes,
but I think it's only a dollar per and
is the best value over sees the World
War One.
Yes.
Yeah,
and not sure what else he's done.
He's done a lot of.
I mean his podcast is just absolutely
amazing.
He's incredible and super humble.
Guy Won't call himself a historian,
but meanwhile has the best history
educational series you can get.
It's a buck,
a buck a piece and they were like an
hour and a half long and they're fucking
incredible.
Yeah,
he's a.
he's a real treasure.
That guy doesn't call himself in his
story because he doesn't use like
primary source material or something
just reads popular works.
I don't know why,
I mean,
I know he who owns the name,
who owns the definition,
he's just really humble,
but his main focus of study,
his entire life has been history,
you know,
and when he does these things where it's
like,
well,
if he calls what he does at podcast,
I need to change.
What I do is I what I call a podcast.
It's just pales in comparison because
we're just sitting here talking.
Right?
Yeah.
Well he does as he prepares for these
things for months and sites,
different sources and different lunches
and then essentially does an educational
entertainment piece.
Yeah.
Maybe that's why he doesn't like the
term his star and his because he's not,
um,
he's not contributing.
He's not contributing to the body of
knowledge.
He's interpreting the body.
Right,
right.
Maybe.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I think he's just super humbled to.
He just wouldn't,
wouldn't say that no matter what,
but somehow,
I don't know why more disturbing to see
a pile of human bodies than it is to see
a pile of the buffalo bones.
Yeah.
I think I told you I'm not talking about
a thousand times what after the custer
massacre,
the guys that that were following the
other soldiers who were coming in after
the massacre and they didn't know what
had happened.
You know they hadn't got word yet,
that custer and his entire command had
been wiped out by the Sioux and northern
Cheyenne and they're riding up the
valley and they're looking off in the
distance and they're in there see all
these sort of white bloody ish things
and all these dark brown things and one
of the guys wrote that.
Their initial impression looking at it
was that cost or must have caught the
Indians in the middle of a buffalo hunt
and what they were seeing was it was
summertime and they were seeing fatty
buffalo carcasses that had been skinned
and that the brown things where the
buffalo hides laid out next to the
carcass.
But when on closer inspection it was.
The brown things were horses,
cavalry,
horses and the white things were
stripped and mutilated soldiers.
A good image wasn't one of the guys,
one of the native Americans.
That was in the little big horn water,
whatever event.
Wasn't he?
One of the guys who toured with wild
bill?
Many of them.
So they were.
They had killed American soldiers and
then they went on this
entertainment tour.
Yeah.
It will be as though it would be like,
this is a fucking risky comparison.
Now I'm not even gonna say Nazi.
No,
no,
I definitely was going to say that x is
way different.
It would be like a
shit.
I'm not going to say I don't want to
make the comparison.
It will come back to haunt me.
Um,
I'm trying to think of something that
would work.
It will be like,
uh,
people that we fought against later
became a media celebrity.
Yeah.
Oh,
I guess they're kind of dealing with it
right now in Columbia where the Farc
right now that Columbia has struck a
peace accord with the FARC and the FARC
are entering into politics,
entering into media.
FARC commanders who spent their entire
life fighting against the Colombia
government.
Many atrocities were traded back and
forth.
They now come on the Columbia or
equivalent of 60 minutes to do
interviews.
Wow,
okay.
So it's like where you have an adversary
that,
that hostilities end in the
reconciliation is so complete and so
quick that you can come,
you can become a media personality.
And this guy was a touring media
personalities.
Dol Rule Guy,
right?
Yeah.
Girl,
who um,
the hospital's name,
the historian,
evanesce,
Connell,
Jesus,
Ge,
all.
And there's some photos of this guy,
right?
Yeah.
There are photos of him.
See if you can find that.
Evanesce O'connell he was,
he was huge.
And um,
the,
the novelist who wrote my favorite Costa
History,
uh,
he says that a girl went through
custer's men like a wolf through sheep
and um,
yeah.
So it's a hard look,
man.
He,
someone asked him how long it took,
how long that fight lasted.
He said it lasted about as long as it
takes a hungry man to eat his dinner.
Wow.
That is a hard look and gentlemen right
there.
Yeah.
That face,
man.
So he toured all over the country.
People would pay to see them pay to get
their photos taken with them.
Wow.
He did selfies.
Selfies with people.
Wow.
What a crazy thing.
That must've been quite a while.
Had some mock war that they would do.
They would come out and reenact the
battle.
Wow.
Yeah,
so you could go down and this would have
been in your own lifetime that people
who,
the families of the men killed at the
battle of little big horn could have
gone down and got their photo taken with
and paid to watch and interacted with
the gentleman who likely clover to their
father's head and with a Tomahawk.
Jesus Christ.
We're not as like we are thinking about
how much worse we are now.
Right.
Is that buffalo bill up there?
I don't know if that's him.
That's him,
but that's from his show.
Wow.
Pumps.
Are we going to say we're not that far
removed?
Oh No.
I was just saying like,
we now think we've gotten to such a
weird spot,
but yeah.
You want to point out that people must
have been a tad more forgiving at the
time.
Well,
there must have been much more used to
death and murder.
Yeah,
because it was so common and it's just,
it was so personal because you know,
you're doing it with hatchets axes and
guns that don't fire very well.
So you do it at close range shooting
people with muskets from and there was
so much more violence then.
Yeah.
So much more depth.
The fact that you grow up and be so old
now and never see a dead person is just
a new idea.
It is pretty crazy.
You know,
I got people my age have never seen a
dead guy.
Yeah.
Well it's a real eyeopener when you see
one.
There's a lot of people that haven't
even seen a dead animal.
Dude,
I could sit,
rattle off the dead people.
I've seen so many in my mind.
How many dead people have I seen?
Yeah.
Not 10.
What have you seen dead people from all?
I saw two people that were not just
dead,
but in bits after a plane crash I saw
where was that?
Fine.
Not even a mile from my house.
I was a little kid.
Yeah.
And then um,
and then a commercial plane or like one
of those little private,
sorry,
57 year old man and a 13 year old kid.
I try.
I tried recently briefly to find time to
go back and find the article.
But the way I,
here's how the story went down is uh,
the way I remember a detail that I
remember very clearly is that this guy,
it was his neighbor kid and they,
he had told this kid's parents,
they were going down the wash the
airplane and look at the airplane and he
decided to take the kid up for a flight.
I don't know if that's true or not.
I was trying to find that article to
confirm that aspect of it.
But I lived on a lake called Middle Lake
and everybody remembers for whatever
reason,
this guy balls our lake a couple times
really low.
There was a guy down on the east end of
the lake named Mr Rupert.
And I remember what was unusual about Mr
Rupert was he would eat freshwater
clams,
which we were forbidden from doing by
her dad.
But
you know,
it's just not as,
people don't regard it as a good
practice at all,
the freshwater clams because the toxins,
you know,
that's another thing I haven't really
looked into why that doesn't happen.
People just generally don't eat fresh
water clans.
But we would go get them and cleaned
them.
And I remember we cleaned a whole
shitload once.
So my dad's like,
no,
but Mr Rupert would eat these freshwater
clams.
And um,
what do you go raw already cook him.
I'm sure he would cook them.
He said,
man,
I saw that plane when a dove down over
the lake,
it went up,
but then dove down again and never came
back up.
And he even told some neighbors this.
The next day when we wake up,
uh,
the sheriff's possy the mounted like our
area had a,
mounted like a bunch of volunteers who
had horses and they were like the
mounted sheriff's Possy,
right?
Like deputized individuals during
emergencies such as this.
They were all loading up their horses to
head out into the woods to look for some
plain and another detail that was told
to me that I wanted to verify that would
I need to do.
I just need to go back and go through
the microfiche where I grew up in find
the article because it was something.
It had a signal on it and the signal was
picked up by some other country even,
but they knew that a plane had gone down
and that was a matter of fact.
Everyone at this point knew that this
plane had gone down
and we were riding around on our bikes
out in the woods.
Just kind of following the sheriff's
Posse guys.
Is there a sort of combing through the
woods and eventually a news helicopter
was hovering over a spot like right at
where a right.
We're at the end of white lake drive
and there was a news helicopter hovered
over there and my two brothers went
directly there on their bikes now as the
younger and if for some reason couldn't
get my mom and then we drove over and we
got to the end of White Lake Road.
We had to walk into the woods and there
was a guy there tried to block my mom
and me from going in there and always
married.
He said,
um,
uh,
if you could go in there,
you better have a strong stomach.
And she's like,
well,
my kids are in there and so we go in
there and Matt and Dan here to stand at
the edge of the hole there.
And they're trying to sort out the trend
to sort out who was who inside this
plane into bags.
I'm not shitting you,
man.
Like,
and yeah,
I have some visual details I remember
from that are just like,
uh,
yeah.
And then it's kind of a cop.
But yeah,
I would like,
like,
and then that was,
you know,
that.
And then I remember we were at our
neighbor,
Mrs Musselman,
um,
I remember we were at her birthday
party.
The cater just fell over dead in front
of everybody.
So like very non war related things.
Right.
That's what's interesting is saying
like,
but you can,
you can see that these are just happen
chance things.
But yeah,
you can go through life.
We just have sort of set up now or you
can be hidden from it.
But then you talked to previous
generations.
Just the,
like,
just,
it was just a part of stuff.
Yeah.
You know,
my old man talked about walking and he
grew up in Chicago.
He talked about walking out of a party
one time.
There's a dead guy at the bottom of the
stairs
that had been beaten to death,
just like Dave,
just like,
then went off to world war two and saw
who knows what.
So yeah,
when people talk about how now were so
violent shit,
there's nothing to support that.
Nothing.
No.
It's this safe.
The safest time to live ever used to be
able to hang people from trees and not
get in trouble for it.
If they're the right color.
Yeah.
Not that long ago.
No,
that's what's crazy about this wild bill
Hickok Shit.
We're talking about what?
18,
70 1880.
When was it?
And what's funny is he was one of the
combatants.
So some of those guys like wild bill
coding,
Wild Bill Hickok Hickock actually had
like a dispute over who got to have the
name,
you know,
Bill Buffalo,
Bill cody,
wild bill Hickok.
There was some other wild bill's I
guess,
and it was like,
it was a popular name,
right?
But they were combatants tube.
So they engaged in these wars and the
fact that you would later get both sides
of the war.
It'd be like if you went and got a bunch
of Germans who were defending the
Normandy beach,
Omaha Beach,
and you've got a bunch of the,
um,
Americans who are starving Omaha beach
and you had a traveling road show in
which they would pretend to inflict mass
casualties on one another for paying
adoring crowds.
How bizarre.
Who came up with the idea for that had
been done ever in history before?
I don't know.
My guess would be,
you know,
there's a guy that was the thing that
I've told people bunch of times no one
ever believes me to distribute.
It's fucking true.
It's true.
There was a guy one time,
you know Niagara Falls,
right?
You've been to Niagara Falls.
No big damn waterfall.
Uh,
you know,
the St Louis,
St Lawrence drains the Great Lakes and
on its way out to the Atlanta,
it was a big ass waterfall.
Niagara Falls.
I'm a guy one time bought it.
There was like a zoo was liquidating its
holdings in a man.
Bought the zoo and bought a barge and
put all of the zoo animals on the barge
and charged a dollar to watch him send
his barge full of animals over the
falls.
Yeah.
Wow.
So,
right.
Yeah.
Not that long ago.
Now I have no js nowadays.
Nowadays they'll put you in a cage.
Yeah.
So it's just.
We've traveled.
What is this,
Jamie?
From the,
when the,
when the show started in the world's
fair,
he got denied from uh,
doing the show outside of the world is
fairly not talking to Weymouth,
cody.
So I don't know which one is which,
but uh,
he found a 14 acre,
a swath of land where you set up stands
for 18,000 people to watch each show and
over 2 million people saw it during like
that,
whatever,
during the world's fair that year was
the first one.
Yeah.
And there weren't even,
uh,
there,
there were 2 million salt,
but there were less,
well under probably way less than $75.
Million people in the country.
Wow.
What year was it in World War Two?
There were $150 million.
That's incredible.
18,000 spectators.
Seventy four Indians from the Pine Ridge
reservation in South Dakota.
Wow.
18,000 spectators must have been amazing
back then.
Yeah.
Now.
But here.
But think about the numbers at that
battle that they.
Historians feel that at that battle,
that was the largest gathering of plains
Indians to have ever occurred.
An encampment of maybe 10,000.
And
how many people were there from?
What's his face?
Costa Costa.
He wrote in to one end of the camp.
That's why it's not well understood.
Like there were other engagements going
on at the same time once when you say
like coster his command was annihilated.
There were other prongs to the attack
that were repelled and beaten,
but it was only like one prong of the
attack that had cost her and that was an
isolated and how many people do you have
when you rode in with about 200 people
and ran into a,
an encampment of 10,000 individuals and
later some of these individuals like
gall and others in interviews said that
even at the time,
our understanding is that these people
were all hopelessly drunk.
Oh my God.
Because it did not make sense what they
were doing.
Wow.
They just didn't know.
It's no one understood that.
That's why custard,
that's why there's still all these costs
are people who just debate and argue and
is like,
uh,
some of his crow scouts.
Okay.
He had some cree or re scouts and cro
scouts who came and told him do not.
You cannot go down there in the morning
there's,
we were playing was attack at daybreak
and they said,
you cannot do that.
That makes no sense.
He said we're going,
they did their death songs,
some of the,
some of his scout sang their death songs
because they knew what they would be
dying in the morning.
And um,
it's debated.
So today,
to what extent did he,
like,
did he believe what his scouts are
telling them?
Okay.
So was it suicide or was it huge?
No one thinks that was suicidal.
It was either that he just didn't really
comprehend what they were telling him or
he was so,
you know,
he was a decorated civil war figure and
probably was a very ardent believer in
the superiority like of his army.
And they were trained soldiers with
discipline that there was just one prong
of a three year,
you know,
a three prong attack or two pronged
attack.
He was riding in the one end of the
village,
but he does a road into the village and
they were just killed.
Right.
And in independent,
in popular depictions,
they always show cost her,
like his,
the last guy standing like there's a
mountain of his dead guys around them,
you know,
and he's still firing his revolver a
with long hair and when in fact he had
short hair at the time.
But uh,
some people think that in looking at it,
he probably.
Yeah.
The great one is here.
Fell coster.
Oh,
great image.
Yeah.
Jamie just pulled up a crazy picture.
So here fell costs and contemporary
picture did say what?
No,
no.
That's the old classic.
There's one that was on the anheuser
busch to the time.
Yeah.
Here fell was a little bit later.
But then I'm the one that was the.
Anheuser Busch won was by a German guy,
I think that was the one you had pulled
up that was like desert Bush had.
It was like their poster.
Oh my God,
that's your fail coster wow.
Which is
considered to be a very accurate.
Was considered to be a pretty accurate
depiction of what was going on.
Now the
custer died early.
I think he died earlier in the skirt,
but she wasn't like the movies.
He's got the flowing blonde hair.
Everyone's dead and he's still firing
away.
Of course he was.
He was probably killed earlier rather
than later in the skirmish.
It's so funny because you're right there
like he's like,
you know,
in a different position.
It's so funny that,
that we've done that,
you know,
that people have taken what they know
most likely we're a storage really
inaccurate accounts and they pass them
down generation to generation.
And it makes you wonder like,
this is what we know now because this is
only a hundred or so years ago.
Like what,
what are we getting when we're getting
some version of something that happened
a thousand years ago or thousand years
ago?
You know,
how distorted
insanely.
Yeah.
But the problem we have as a culture I
think is when someone goes to fix,
when someone goes to challenge our
popular perceptions,
um,
it's,
it's branded as revisionist and somehow
like loses,
right?
It becomes almost like a,
it's credentials or tarnished.
Do.
Remember the guy,
I can't remember what politician,
Jamie,
we'll pull it up.
There was a politician who said,
um,
he famously said,
you know,
her,
we realized that Paul revere the,
the,
the ride of Paul revere was,
didn't really happen like fabricated
from whole cloth.
Right?
Right.
There was a politician said,
I love Paul Revere.
Whether he wrote or not.
Well,
I mean,
when we were kids,
we were taught Columbus,
discovered the United States.
Yeah.
I mean,
we didn't figure that out until.
It's still amazing that it wasn't like
the West indies.
And to this day it's still amazing that
they celebrate that guy when you find
out that he was a fucking monster.
I mean,
the,
what was it?
Uh,
I believe it was a,
I'm a minister or someone who has some
religious person who came with them at
the time,
uh,
left a journal about the atrocities
committed directly by Columbus and his
men when they hacked off arms for
people,
couldn't bring them back.
Gold.
And I mean,
just horrific shit.
Smash babies on rocks did it right in
front of them.
And this guy was a firsthand account of
what we're supposed to believe.
I mean,
who knows how much of what he's saying
is accurate,
but if any of it is accurate,
Columbus was a fucking monster.
Yeah.
I think there,
what it stems from is that from the
perspective in Europe at the time he
had,
he had solidified and put some shit
together that people had been kind of
pecking around the edges of.
Right.
Whether it's continental existed.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and yeah,
just had,
it was like a leap forward at the time.
Yeah.
How crazy is that?
But the fact that it becomes that,
right?
Did he like,
you know that in some people's minds,
like somehow established America.
Yeah.
And that we take a day off of school
because of it.
It's really crazy.
It's bizarre.
Columbus Day.
I mean we still to this day it's 2017
kids get Columbus Day off,
don't they?
But now it's like,
here's the thing,
now that no one,
now that now that sort of the consensus,
right,
the popular consensus is that,
um,
he was a one of many players involved in
sort of putting together what was here
and sort of outlining where it was and
how to get here.
Um,
he was one of a bunch of players,
you know,
almost certainly not the first,
uh,
no one cares about that.
Meaning what they mean is you're like
saying like,
I uphold the idea of western
civilizations,
annexation of the new world as being a
good thing.
So when someone says,
when someone gets pissed at the
revisionists for questioning the
legitimacy of Columbus,
they're not actually talking about what
he specifically did.
It's become,
it's become a proxy for the cultural
annexation of the new world and to say,
oh,
I hate Columbus.
He's an asshole.
They take it to me and you're saying
that,
um,
uh,
you're questioning our claim on the
western hemisphere and that it was a bad
thing.
I think that's why people are annoyed by
it.
I don't think people were too much
annoyed by it anymore because the thing
that's pretty much been established
there.
Columbus is a really bad,
but no one's gone in and undid the day
have.
Have they.
Is there any.
Is there any kind of change them around,
don't they?
Well,
they should probably come up with
another name for it.
You know,
a Api a.
it's still a day,
right?
I think so.
Pretty sure.
Yeah.
It is kinda crazy though.
I'm not,
I'm not here to defend the day,
but I do understand that kind of how
that shit came to beat.
Yeah,
I understand it.
It just seems pretty incredible that
just 500 years ago here it goes to war
against Columbus Day and the Washington
Post.
Yes.
It's waged by the same people who were
waging a war against Christmas.
His is really.
That's crazy.
Indigenous People's Day in favor of
indigenous peoples.
Yeah.
No,
it makes sense.
Give us a day off.
We'll take it.
I'm generally like little movements,
like little cultural movements like
that.
I'm generally not a receptive.
I don't know.
I don't try to read too much into them.
If I woke up tomorrow and telling me
that we had decided,
you know,
that people got together and decided
against Columbus Day,
I wouldn't like do a lot of soul
searching on that.
Well,
you know,
you don't work a traditional job
anywhere or go to school where you take
that day.
Oh yeah.
I think people that lost the day,
they're like too.
That's my day,
man.
Yeah.
It's just hard to imagine as I hit
walleyes my buddy doug every year.
Yeah,
you'd be bumped.
It's just hard to imagine that,
you know,
500 plus years ago they really didn't
know in Europe about the continental
United States.
I,
that's,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
We were talking about earlier talking
about violence or violent,
more violent than I think that we're so
tripped up by the upheaval caused by the
digital age.
Right.
And everything.
Like,
you know,
I just changed our sleep practices and
just everything.
You know,
it's a major upheaval.
Yeah.
But picture that picture that in your
lifetime,
they all like,
you become aware
that
the,
the earth did see that there are,
you know,
three times as many or whatever as many
civilizations on earth is that you
thought there were.
Yeah.
I mean that's a huge thing to grapple
with
a huge thing to grapple with.
People that had history,
people that had boats,
they were seafaring had more history
than you.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Or to think that one day,
and this is not too long ago,
so you know,
some of our grandparents remember this,
to think that one day we had devised the
contraption that was capable of ending
life on earth and that these
contraptions could be initiated by the
distant actions of a handful of people
that
that's a change,
right?
Yeah.
The nuclear era.
Here's the craziest change in the
nuclear era,
from the invention of an airplane to
someone dropping a nuclear bomb from an
airplane is less than 50 years now.
I think Wright brothers 19.
Oh,
three,
right?
Nineteen,
six,
93,
early 1900.
[inaudible] sustained a flight with a
heavier than air vehicle.
And then in 1945 they dropped an atomic
bomb.
That's crazy.
That's inside my life.
Someone was like,
I knew this airplane shit was going to
take off,
but that is probably one of the biggest
changes ever in terms of like the amount
of in 50 years in the world to go from
no air travel at all to dropping a
nuclear bomb out of an airplane in less
than 50 years.
Yeah.
And to then have it be that it's a
staple of,
uh,
of,
of American life,
they did not just with other people like
space travel.
You're like,
okay,
it's this flood of information,
but it's not affect me.
But with that,
it's like that's now how you get around.
Yeah.
You know,
that you like at a time when you wanted
to cross the country,
you would lose a large percentage of
your party to death.
Right.
You had to plan ahead who would take
many,
many months to being just a thing.
You just do on a whim.
Now I do believe like I accept that we
are a state of upheaval right now and I
think there were probably impacting
ourselves in ways we don't fully
understand how so digital devices.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
Just how you run your day.
Yeah,
no doubt.
How you spend your time,
how you run your day will ever go to a
restaurant and you see a whole group of
people just staring at their phone.
Yeah.
We're laughing with their day.
If you're staying at the baggage claim,
not looking at your phone,
people will think you're nuts.
It's true.
My friend is looking around trying to
make conversation with people.
My friend,
a conversation.
His life has happened with some over.
So I was in starbucks drink and a coffee
just sitting there and staring at the
wall like a fucking lunatic.
What,
what are they out to you?
They're going to start killing people.
They're not doing anything with their
phone.
Um,
it,
it's a big thing.
But what are the helpful thing?
I guess one of the help it just bring it
full circle.
One of the helpful things
you know about traveling or about like
just reading about history is you stop,
you lose some of that sense of
specialness about thinking that the life
you're living in,
the moment you're living it as this
great test of humanity or some like
super peculiar thing going out when you
realize that people have always been
involved with and struggle with
cataclysmic upheaval,
you know,
and then to go in to indigo witness some
other people in some version of that
transition
is pretty healthy man.
Maybe in the long term,
let's just traveling,
going to see how other people do stuff.
It's unsettling,
but probably ultimately pretty.
Yeah.
Good for you.
Yeah,
I think it's very good for you.
Just anything that enhances perspective,
it gives you like another layer that you
could consider when you think about life
on earth.
We're so used to our own environment,
our own ways.
It's like you were talking about talking
to these people and asking them like,
why don't you eat monkeys and now we're
stony monkeys have.
Has He ever been to a supermarket?
That's a good question.
A couple of years ago when I was
mentioning that I had mentioned to you
that,
that the,
the,
that a couple of American companies who
have a to have like some conservation
spending,
they do,
they were training some guys from real
village.
They were training some of them to,
uh,
just how to interface with Westerners.
And as part of that,
he went up to,
he might have even gone up to the
Bahamas to go for a couple days to a fly
fishing lodge.
So I'm getting.
So yeah,
he flew on a commercial aircraft.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
I'm just so pleased to see.
But he's peculiar in that way now I've
brought up to him.
I'm trying to talk him into coming up
and going.
I want to take them on ice fishing trip
so I'll take loads your Alaska fish to
the ice because what I want him to
understand is,
um,
I'm so uncomfortable
with him physically uncomfortable with
the,
with
everything biting me all the time,
just everything.
It's just extremely uncomfortable.
And to him at standard,
yeah,
it's comfortable,
but he's never like if he hadn't done
that trip or you know,
or just all of his siblings and most
other people's village,
they never experienced,
you know,
they never experienced 50 degrees
Fahrenheit.
Now what is it like to them when it
comes to bugs so they have any sort of
resistance to mosquitoes or anything
along those lines.
They don't care about it nearly as much
as we care about it.
Do they get the same amount of bytes
though too?
They get chewed up like we do.
They complain about tick bites and
stuff,
but generally it doesn't seem to bother
me like we do because it's just a part
of everyday life.
But you got to get used to,
you know,
and like and like hanging out in
Bolivia.
You get bit by bees and wasps at about
the same rate that you'd get bit by
mosquitoes if you rat like some fourth
of July thing out at your uncle's pond,
you know,
shooting fireworks off at night on the
edge of a cat tail.
Marsh was like your skin a bit just like
wake up and you start getting bit by
bees and wasps so they just get,
just kind of used to it and then you'd
say like,
I remember when I got stung by a bullet
and asking like,
Hey,
how many times you been stung by a
bullet dance and love them and be like,
I couldn't even begin to guess how many
times I've been stung by a bullet dance,
but it's like,
but they just suffer different.
So what I want to do is I want him to
experience suffering
while watching me not suffer.
So like I want him to look at me with
all.
Okay.
And so to do this I want them to come up
and ice fish wrong and take them up.
And I got A.
I got a friend who likes to go on.
He likes to get on snow machines in
February or March out of fair banks.
And they go overnight camping on snow
machines,
fishing through the ice for Bourbon
Bourbon.
Oh,
for a cold.
Freshwater links are low.
You know,
why they call lawyers is when you got a
bourbon,
his Ah,
his heart sway back next to his asshole.
So they call them lawyers or vent,
you know,
fish have a,
like a,
like a color awake and they have a uni
whole,
you know,
we have like a bird.
Yeah.
We have a couple outlets and they have a
single outlet for waste and sexual
exchange.
Um,
so yeah,
lawyer,
Bourbon,
fresh water,
laying.
Poor man's lobster is another word for
it.
So northern fish,
it looks like if you combined a snake
and a bull frog kind of A.
Yeah,
I want to take them out to camp in a
tent in 40 degree below weather right
there.
Wow.
What a cool looking fish are very good
to eat.
Yeah.
Very good.
Wow.
Now they commonly caught through the ice
or did people catch them on the street?
That looks.
That's a northern peasant.
Dorothy?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
No,
it's kind of a bourbon or not.
But in the Great Lakes there.
Alaska.
Yeah.
There's bourbon everywhere.
So does it tastes like lobster?
Is that why they call it a poor milk?
The reason they call it poor man's
lobster,
he doesn't really tastes like lobster,
but it's suitable for boiling it and
dipping it in butter and cocktail sauce
and eating.
Really?
Yeah.
But y'all should make fish sandwiches
with it.
Huh?
They even sell that shit commercially.
Bourbon guys that have like guys that
like a native American.
So in the northern Great Lakes you have
a Jibo to Jibo.
I Indians still carry on White Lake.
They fish for great lakes,
white fish.
They trap net,
great legs,
White Fish.
They're able to sell a bycatch of
Bourbon and they have restaurants and
like in the cup I got some friends that
do it and they got restaurants in the
ups that they sell their bourbon into
and they make burgers.
Sandwiches.
Huh?
Freshwater link to take them on ice
fishing trip.
And um,
but for him to leave,
like he doesn't go into Georgetown,
which is the capital of this country.
He'd have to go into Georgetown and
start like trying to figure out some
kind of a visa situation and a passport.
Does he have a birth certificate?
I don't know what he has.
I told him that I would try to help him
with all that,
but he said it's like a very daunting
idea that you would like go and leave
the country for that.
You'd go in and stay in Georgetown,
but he has been on a commercial flight.
He did that trip.
Yeah.
So he has done it yet.
He has done it.
So he had to get a passport in order to
do it.
His passport didn't last long and now he
has no passport anymore is what he's
telling me when I was asking him about
the feasibility of this and then you
don't need a visa for there,
but he needed a visa to come here,
but I'm going to figure it out.
I want to have them up so bad.
Wow.
Him and his brother Dennis.
One of the things that surprised,
like one of the things you get is um,
you know,
you're from what state were you born in?
New Jersey.
Yeah.
See,
it's like you've been all over the
place,
right?
Imagine that.
Imagine that you hunted and fished and
farm and that's all you did.
So you're always on the land.
Yeah,
and you've done it all within a 25 mile,
a 20 mile radius of your home,
so you're outside hunting and fishing or
farming or gathering in the jungle every
day and you're in your thirties or
forties and you've done it in a radius
of 20 miles to what level you understand
your spot and without the distractions
of the digital shit and without the
distractions of an occupation.
Oh,
he doesn't work at all.
Not,
I mean,
now he did.
He guides a little bit every year for
the fish.
He guides a little bit,
but typically not like most days he's
not engaged in that activity.
So the spatial awareness as the thing
that's most striking to me in spending
time with,
with these individuals is,
um,
everything I'm interested in,
what they noticed and what they never
miss
it.
It's like you realize that all of the
bits of information that you're able to
contain your head to allow you to
function and carry on,
right?
You're like a comedian and you do shit
with mma and you have a very successful
podcast and you have a family and you're
digitally very astute.
And you have opinions about fucking
coffee,
write all this shit you're widely read,
right?
That's like all your sort of fill up
your brain with as much as it can hold.
But for them it's like it seems to be
from my perspective is like all of that
breadth of knowledge but crammed into
the natural world
to where every plant,
every tree,
water its use as what are the other
things and it's like they know as much
like they know as much as we know,
but it's just focused in a way that our
breadth of knowledge,
which,
which would probably be astounding to
them if they realize all the shit we
knew about,
but they're all that,
all those bits of information or just
applied in a different way down to like
a granular understanding of the jungle.
It would probably be very bizarre for
them to see us.
Like walk out to this parking lot,
these,
a little patches of like plants.
We don't have a fucking clue what they
are.
We pass through them like they,
they,
they're just peripheral.
There is no like,
I don't know what that is.
Yeah.
Wow.
No,
they know everything and there's
toxicity.
How many thousands and thousands of
different varieties of plants.
There's no at various times there's 1500
species of birds.
Listen,
I like,
there was never a moment when I heard a
bird call.
There was a.
I'd never said,
hey,
what's that bird that everyone there?
It didn't say what the bird was.
Bird sounds just from sounds
like,
like in the shit that,
like it,
it,
it's almost something you have to go see
is um,
the ability to just like move through
the jungle and notice everything now.
Are they like the people in Bolivia
where they're barefoot most of the time?
Yeah.
But you know,
that's another bummer is getting more
into shoes,
man.
A row has still likes to take his shoes
off when he goes into the jungle.
We went into the jungle after some curse
out and uh,
and he,
he pulled his shoes off to be extra
quiet.
But yeah.
So he'll now and then put flip flops on
now and before it is.
No Way.
Wow.
Do they still have the weird feet that
are all this catalyst and tozer spread
laid out?
It's very strange the way their feet
look real strange.
I wasn't,
you know,
and I was in the Philippines one time in
the highlands where people are just
hiking mountain trails,
you know,
severe topography on rocky ground and
the feet there,
I've never seen anything like it
barefoot.
It's almost unrecognizable as a human
foot really from your perspective of
human foot,
what it look like.
Have uh,
have,
have your inner man.
He was their photos,
their feet out Luzon island,
hot,
Luzon island,
highlands,
Coalinga,
k a l I n g a feet.
I don't know,
try that.
There's probably some high resolution
national geographic's if this,
if he's any good at his job,
you will be seeing some crazy feat in a
moment.
You don't.
Another thing I wanted to
share as you had mentioned,
a sort of a surreal image is uh,
you know,
watching a woman in a decay in why shirt
like digging turtle eggs for food,
um,
through there's,
there's flowers or you know,
everything's in bloom,
right?
Um,
it was just the beginning of the rainy
season,
sort of some rain,
like everything is in bloom and he's
flowers just all fall flowers of all
variety,
hang out over the river and sometimes
you'll pass through.
It just has this like warm floral smell
that just,
it's astounding.
I'm it remind me of,
you know,
and in the end of apocalypse now when
Kurt's,
when Captain Willard finally catches up
with Kurtz and Kurtz,
ask them where he's from and he mentions
Ohio and Kurt's tells him about a river
trip he took with his father on the Ohio
river when the guardian he wearing in
bloom,
you know,
he talks about the smell in the end of
apocalypse now,
but these flowers and smell like that.
But when the rain would come,
it's going to.
I can't even see what you got some feet.
Oh,
you'll find some feet,
boy.
One trying to find something better.
Here's a.
So it would rain.
It would knock the all the flowers into
the river
and you know,
like the way.
Yeah.
I love talking well so.
Well from grasping.
Wow.
They're like almost like a gorilla's
feed.
Yeah,
from like from wrapping your,
like wrapping your feet around thing
rocks and stuff like that.
That one in the middle's I saw,
I saw,
I saw like a number,
like not yet quite a few people that had
faith resembled that from,
from,
from [inaudible],
like you know,
down in the Amazon and other areas.
You're just walking on soft ground,
you know,
but imagine if you're just like walking
on slippery rocks and you're using your
feet in a way that's not even uncommon.
So we're,
we're looking at for people that are
just listening to this,
it's like at the middle of their foot,
especially that one foot in the middle
to the right.
It's like he's tea.
It's taking a turn,
like a hard turn,
like a 15 degree plus turn.
Why do those seem like disembodied feet?
Because there's just photograph in the
feet.
I guess
real old.
This is like a big article about people
from the Philippines at thing from the
same area.
Oh Huh.
So wow,
go back to it for a second,
Jamie,
because what we're seeing in this is um,
this massive spacing between the big toe
and then the first toe to the point
where it's like an opposable.
That's an opposable toe.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It seems like almost like an opposable
toe.
Yeah.
Almost like a thumb now.
I'm sure.
What's at play there too?
Really fucked.
I could make you wonder like at one
point in time was it like that,
that
that's the thing is you wonder is and,
and I don't know the answer to this,
but my guess would be that over time you
know that they're not starting out with
your foot.
Like over time,
that that's been something that's been
selected for.
Right?
In a population?
Yes.
People like height or like he did just
like this guy's feet.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
We're what we're looking at what looks
like frog,
but that's not even,
that's not even crazy shoe.
That's,
isn't that a,
that's North America people feet and
this guy were h u a o r a n I.
How do you pronounce that?
Harani.
I'd have to check where that is.
It's bizarre,
but it really does show you from fucking
wearing shoes your whole life and given
the different environment like that.
That's insane.
Like what we're looking at here,
they literally look like thumbs,
like they're sticking out of the side,
but it's the same structure as a human
foot,
meaning that it's the same length of
toes and just you see that from using it
that way.
They've just developed this incredible.
You know what's really crazy?
What is one of the hallmarks of
civilization that shows like a really
poor choice and footwear when your feet
go the other way,
when they go in an ineffective
direction,
they they get,
they get that hammertoe and they climb
over each other.
These is,
these people have functional feet to the
point where you know they could probably
hold something with their feet.
Yeah.
When I look at a.
When I look at my wife's feet,
I feel like she's got a foot disease
very much shaped by a lifetime of office
footwear.
It's awful.
Especially with women.
They get that Hammertoe,
that Bunyan thing where their,
their toes are kind of crossed over to
the center of that thing.
Well,
it's so weird.
It's a weird choice that someone is
decided that women should shove their
toes into these pointy things.
But,
but uh,
just like with the,
that I saw the,
a group of individuals lock onto
polarized sunglasses as being the shit.
Um,
I,
if you went back in five years,
I'm telling you,
instead of bringing beaten,
being barefoot was gonna be wearing
shoes.
What if you got those women high heel
shoes and said,
this is what all the women in the
stretch.
Of course you could take awhile,
but you get.
Oh,
that's disgusting though.
That's foot banding is fucked up right
there.
That's just insane.
Can you tell them,
looking at your toes from binding your
feet,
foot binding in China?
Yeah.
Well you soft tissue.
It's very flexible.
So go,
uh,
go to Cirque du Solei.
Look at those people could do their
bodies.
The human body is pretty bizarre and its
ability to adapt,
but it,
yeah.
You know,
those groups that used to bind their
children's head to that back to flag in
your head out,
well,
how about those people and what part of
the world was it a where they have that
in the incas,
the where they have those lines,
the Nazca lines,
you know,
and they found all these skulls from
people back then were they,
it stretched their heads out,
almost made their heads look like
aliens.
Yeah,
there you go.
But,
uh,
see if you find the Inca Inca skulls,
it's so much so that a lot of the really
loony people said,
look,
they're trying to be like the aliens
that have come down and given them
knowledge and.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Have you ever been down to,
um,
do you remember those?
They're,
they're,
they're held in Salta,
Argentina.
I went to see him one time.
But those children,
did they found that were in tombed at
the top of a mountain and they were
basically freeze dried?
No,
it's perfectly preserved.
Children.
What would happen to them?
Well,
they were taken up and given as the
offering.
So first it seems based on the stuff
they had with them that they were prayed
through the incan empire and people
lavish them with gifts and when they
look at the isotopes and their bodies,
it's like their diet,
their whole lives,
they had just had potatoes,
but then you can see the,
toward the end of their lives,
they're very well fed with meat and fish
and all kinds of stuff.
And they had just innumerable treasures,
a gold pieces carved pieces.
So they were taking it seems as though
they were taken throughout the empire.
And what,
what's really funny about this,
speaking of Columbus earlier is it was
like,
yeah,
so it's like as best they haven't dated
exactly.
But it seems like,
I mean it seems like we're talking
about,
you know,
Columbus 1492.
It's like we're talking about 1491.
Wow.
So the height of this empire at,
at the,
the height of the empire butting up
against it's dramatic and sudden
collapse with European contact.
But they took a.
yeah,
I went to see.
And um,
she was the only,
they made a deal with indigenous people
where they only put one on display at a
time,
but she was on display when I was there
and what do they have their encapsuled.
So they took them,
well,
I'll tell you how they came to be first.
So
they were finally dressed,
had a lot of ornaments and things with
them had been very well fed and the,
the older group and they took them out
to the high peak,
I can't remember how they might've been
14 or 15,000 feet above sea level.
And they built a little tune for him and
sat him in the tomb.
They were drunk,
they had a lot of rice wine in their
bodies when they died.
Uh,
the oldest one mostly putting up some
kind of struggle because she was hitting
the head with a hammer and acts and they
were just laid out in this thing and
then kept over with rocks and it's very
stable environment.
So they froze.
And then,
you know,
we use now like backpacking food is
freeze dried food.
Yeah.
They used to have,
they used to do a very similar thing
with by just taking potatoes and storing
them at high elevations were what?
Freeze drying is your liquid.
It's like you freeze something and then
expel the liquid.
Where liquid goes from a gaseous
[inaudible] goes from a solid to a gas
without passing through its liquid
state.
So when you freeze dry food,
you like freeze dry,
you put it in a freezer and get super
cold and then you start.
Then you start putting it under a vacuum
to point where all the water goes
immediately to a gash state doesn't pass
through a liquid state,
so it holds its form,
but all the water's gone.
If it goes to a liquid state,
then it collapses,
but just hold it's form in the non
water.
Parts of the cells just stay bound in
their natural shape.
So they were in this position and
eventually just like expelled tons of
water without ever thrown out.
And when they found them,
you can even see the that they had been
chewing cocoa leaves because the high
elevation,
the kids still have dried coca leaves on
their lips.
Dude,
it's wild.
Yeah.
Me and my wife went there to look at
them.
Where does it now?
It's in Salta,
Argentina.
Wow.
Near the border was very near the border
of Bolivia.
I wanted to ask you something totally
unrelated,
but it came up because you've talked
about freeze dried foods.
I know you cook a lot,
but have you ever.
I know you eat those mountain house
things,
but have you ever tried to make your
own.
Have you ever tried to dehydrate some of
your wild game?
Oh yeah.
I'm dehydrated.
I mean anytime you make jerky or
dehydrate and stuff,
but have you ever made chili and things
like that where you could rehydrated in
the field trial they've ever made
dehydrated?
No.
I've assembled a lot of dehydrated
things,
but I've never d like at what point,
how many ingredients need to be in
something before it becomes like a
recipe?
[inaudible] couple chemical.
That's a recipe.
It pemmican that's got two things.
Pemmican pulverize meet with liquid fat
poured over the top of it.
Did you know what that is?
No.
People.
Fuck that up all the time.
What feminine is?
I've never heard of it before,
I don't think so.
It'd be like the original road food.
You dry meat into Jerky,
air-dry a Jerky,
then you pull it into what looks like
Sawdust and then you take in stirred and
liquified fat.
I made some from a buffalo kill and I
wrote my buffalo book.
I made Pemmican from that and I was.
And I had it in my fridge.
This as an experiment.
I kept it for seven years.
Survival food that can last 50 years.
But that's not pemmican.
It's not,
it doesn't look like it looks like jerky
sticks because it's not pulverized.
People just now started all of a sudden
call.
And like,
I'm not saying everybody missed,
hardly everybody messes up,
but it's like a thing that gets messed
up.
So,
um,
what was I getting at?
What are asking about?
No,
I asking you to hydrate or dehydrate a
bunch of different things and combined
it into a recipe that I then bring with
me.
The reason I like the reason I used the
hydrated food and a lot of backpack
hunters use dehydrated food is because
I'm.
If you have a a,
a dish made up of dehydrated
ingredients.
They have different hydration times.
Okay.
So if you do beans like,
like a piece of meat is going to be
digestible to you.
My piece of dehydrated meat that's then
hydrated is going to be digestible to
you.
A dehydrated being,
yeah.
Might take 30 or 40 minutes before it's
going to be in a condition and it
doesn't rip you apart.
If you fuck yourself up,
eat straight dried beans.
What happens?
Just,
it's just you're off.
Yeah.
You don't know.
You're someone doesn't know what to do
with it,
man.
Well knows what to do with.
It starts producing voluminous amounts
of gas,
right?
It's off,
it's horrible.
But with,
with,
if you could,
if you take food and cook it to a ready
to eat steak
and then freeze dry it,
it,
uh,
you can rehydrate it Kinda like
simultaneously if you do everything
right now.
One word were like a hamburger,
right?
If you're hydrated a hamburger and then
you add water to it,
you're going to wind up with a soggy ass
been.
So the trick is like finding things that
are gonna in a hot water bath are going
to all come back to life kind of at the
same time.
But places that make backpack food out
of just dehydrated but not freeze dried
ingredients is a recipe for disaster.
Really.
Some people liked that shit.
But for day in,
day out consumption,
um,
I'm a freeze dry man and it's freeze
dried.
Something you can do at home,
you'd have to buy a sublimation chamber.
So No.
What does the sublimation chamber,
what does that look?
It's a chamber in which sublimation,
you know what it looks like.
It looks like the,
it looks like a submarine,
really small,
but it's very heavy duty because we are
doing is you're taking,
you're taking food,
you take ready foods and freeze it.
Right?
And then you put it into a sublimation
chamber and pull a very strong vacuum on
it.
And the air pressure gets to a point
where the liquid cellmates and goes
directly to a gas state and you condense
it on another surface inside the
chamber,
but it's out of the food.
Then you take the food out and it's like
glass.
You can shatter it.
That's freeze dried food.
But it rehydrates in a real nice way.
I have heard we a lot of it because we
do a lot of back country trips.
I've heard everyone's complaints about
it,
but it's like from my perspective,
which I will argue is a well informed
perspective.
It's like it's the lesser of two evils.
It's not that bad for day in,
day out consumption.
I think that the companies that are do
freeze dry it just better in my opinion
now when I say that these children are
freeze dried,
I think some people,
you know,
people are going to challenge that
because it's not technically freeze
dried,
but like a similar thing going on where
they're keeping their form but shedding
their water and be
shedding water,
keeping their form of being frozen and
preserved for a long time.
So yeah,
it's a trip because I was reading a
podcast or reading a podcast,
listening to a podcast rather with this
guy was talking about how he's doing
that with his own food,
for backpacking trips,
dehydrating it.
Oh Man.
Why not?
Things like Chili or things along those
lines.
It's busy cooking Chili and then
dehydrate or just dehydrating the
components.
Think dehydrated.
The components.
I think he was talking about dehydrating
the meat and dehydrating pasta.
Like like something,
you know,
like taking some meat with sauce and
putting it together with the pasta.
Now my brother one time,
he's a very,
a frugal man.
He didn't realize is that the right
word?
He just hates a to see food,
go to waste.
He one time had a bunch of roommates and
they all moved out and left a ton of
rice and you got sick of cooking rice
because it takes too long.
He cooked all the rice and then spread
it out on sheets and dehydrated it and
is a hydrator and,
and,
and reverse engineered instant rice.
That's insane.
Does it take that long?
What does rice tastes like?
Twenty minutes?
It seems like it takes more time to do
that talk to him.
So this is the same guy.
Is this the same guy that found the
hobos underwear and stole it?
Yup.
And the same guy that,
um,
one time our,
our dear,
late friend was getting married and uh,
his bride,
his bride at the wedding was at his
bride to b's House and a neighbor was
away on vacation and the neighborhood
was away on vacation,
said,
you know,
since we're out of town,
if you guys want to use our home for
some of your wedding guests,
go ahead.
And so all the groomsmen were lodged up
in this house of this man.
We didn't know who was a neighbor of his
wife's parents.
And uh,
I don't know why,
but my brother got the snooping around
and this guy freezer and found that he
had,
had.
He had a bull elk in there that had been
in there for seven years and he had like
this crisis,
this moral crisis where he's trying to
figure out,
is it morally worse to steal or morally
worse to allow this man to waste this
meet?
How long was it built?
We'll book stay.
Good.
If you freeze it,
you were fucking pushing it.
A seven years.
Seven years.
Like what is what is commonly agreed
upon?
It depends who you ask.
If you asked me the way I treat trim,
the way I cut trim and rap,
I don't even blink at two years.
Two years is fine.
Yeah.
The way I cut trim and rap.
But when you start seeing for years,
you get a little weird.
Well,
a thing that I don't let it go.
I,
I've never done it.
I would have to think it's going to
start to go [inaudible] the texture,
the texture will change.
The texture will change.
Um,
seven years.
There's two things going on.
One,
you're borderline until you're starting
to get the idea that this guy isn't
gonna eat that thing,
right?
Yeah.
So he waited out in his head and when he
left he had a bunch of that meet with
them and took them home and aid because
he just hated to see,
uh,
oh.
Outgoing waste.
How did it tastes?
Seven years old.
I remember we did the ask them.
Wow.
But his standard of good is different
than your standard,
his standard of good as acceptable in
cases like that.
So here's a weird crisis though.
It makes sense.
But he,
throughout his whole life,
he always is running into these
situations like where he cannot,
he cannot let food go to waste.
So he's like,
if I talk to him right now,
there's probably 10 more things like
that that have happened to them since I
talked to him last where he's like,
when he found like he found in his
alleyway one time and he living in
Montana and still lives in my town
living in Bozeman founder and his
alleyway,
like a discarded a discarded cash from a
homeless man and ate all that guys food.
And he was a phd candidate at the
university.
You grew up with them.
So I've ever understand him.
The first time he,
here's where he kind of like,
we're not where it came from,
but he drew a bear tag when we were in
Michigan and it was hard to get a bear
take at the time.
And he drew a bear tag.
And the only way to hunt bears and the
ups is like,
you know,
you're not,
you're not going to spot stock him
because it's flat ground and you can't
see shit.
Right?
Oh,
you use dogs.
Are you gonna use bait.
There's.
You never see a bear.
So he started to bait pound way.
He was feeding his bait pile ahead of
the season was just dumpster diving.
So as he's dumpster diving,
it's like he's living off.
Not only is he baiting the bear with the
dumpster food,
but he's like living off the dumpster
dive and food that he found to because
he liked,
discovered this great richmond November
him.
He found on that shit.
He found this big box of boxes of
expired bugles.
You know those little crackers?
Yeah.
The people like put cheese with shoot
Cheez whiz into the open ended that
bugle.
And I've got a picture of him.
He just walking the walk through the
woods with boxes of bugles under his arm
and get out.
And he'd be like dumping them out for
the bear and just eating the vehicles
to.
And then he'll walk back with a handful
of bugles,
just hate to see wasted food.
His old girlfriend had a job cooking
like the brown food and the Albertson's,
you know,
like the display case where they fry all
it was like burritos and shit.
And um,
they were,
she was bringing all that home and they
were living off the food that was going
to the garbage and they came to her and
said,
you can't steal this food.
And then she started stealing it
quietly.
Wow.
He can't stand to see food go to waste.
Well that's probably noble,
you know,
it's extra nice is he works for the
Usta.
So it's good to know that a person like
that is involved and um,
you know,
is at least in the room with people who
are thinking about food systems.
Is it good?
Because it seems like you'll fucking
anything dude.
He will.
He's on a different level,
on a different level of toughness and
shit.
He's the guy who was arm and shrinking
because morale is trying to hook you up
with.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's got a gun.
Did he do anything about that?
Nope.
Oh Jesus,
that's not good.
No.
Once you get that atrophy,
it's a very tough to get it back.
The ways nerves regenerate takes a long
time.
It's like a half an inch a year.
He chronicles.
It's decay by taking a.
he's got a 30 pound a kettle bell and
he,
he was chronicling his decay by watching
how many just tricep.
So County Hmi,
tricep curls.
He could do it.
That kettlebell with one arm,
one with the other.
And I think last time we were talking to
him it was 30 or something like 30 on
one side and 10 on the other side.
Oh Jesus,
that's bad.
So,
uh,
that's a neck issue then he's like a c,
three or c four or something like that.
He's gone,
he's gone.
He hasn't,
I shouldn't say he hasn't done anything
about it.
He's probably,
if he's listening to this,
he's probably cringing because he would
feel that he has.
But I'm tell him if he's listening this
a couple things you need to do.
If it's,
it seems to me like it's a neck issue
because,
uh,
when,
when you start getting elbows and things
where your arm starts atrophying,
usually it's a cervical disc which is
somewhere up in here.
Um,
what,
what he should do is get a neck
decompression device.
They're very,
they're inexpensive.
They hook over a door,
you put it on with Velcro,
you strap it,
and I have one,
uh,
it,
it hangs on a thing.
It's like you're hanging yourself by
your Chin may get some room in there for
all those nerves.
Exactly.
And well,
same principles,
these toes spreading out.
And then other also toasts,
smashing up.
You can kind of soft tissue,
stretch out your neck and decompress all
those areas.
A lot of people have it from bad
posture.
A lot of people have from athletics.
I got it from Jujitsu,
from all this,
you know,
getting your neck yanked on.
See that thing right there,
that lady has.
Yeah,
that's a shitty one because that one's
working on a bag of water that doesn't
work with a neck like mine.
You need,
you need to be able to hang on,
hang on rhino on the other.
I had a,
I have a thing where I go like,
just click,
click,
and then I let myself hang from my neck.
And um,
it's just like that,
just like that.
See how that guy's just sitting there
reading a magazine and you can adjust
that.
So there's a little,
a cord.
It's tough to see in this photo,
but there's a cord you pull sorta like a
plunger on.
When I was old school toilets,
he pulled that click,
click,
click CEO.
He's pulling it right there.
Yep.
And then you just relax and you just
gotta learn how to go with it and sort
of relaxed.
And it feels weird at first because a
lot of pressure but it's pulling your
neck literally pulling your neck.
You can feel.
Sometimes when I'm really relaxed I feel
like pop.
I feel like something pop little tissue
separation's in there.
Does it have,
do you feel that it's gotten better
longterm?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
And it feels like really relaxing,
like after it's over I feel like,
oh,
I feel like it just takes a weight off
of,
you know,
I think there's a tremendous amount.
I think sitting is terrible.
These,
these seats that we're in right now are
exceptional because they're ergonomic
chairs.
You use them right if you use them.
Right.
I'm pretty cautious about sitting up
straight.
But from back injuries I've been very,
very cautious about working out all the
muscles around my back,
which I didn't really.
I just worked out and figure those
things to take care of themselves.
Now are treat them as like a,
just like brushing my teeth,
like my spinal column and all those
supporting muscles in the spine.
Those are huge.
They need,
they need to be exercised.
And especially if you do anything,
like you guys pack out a lot of weight.
Yeah.
That's a big one.
And that's where he feels that
he had SCIATICA.
Right?
That's lower.
That's a yard.
That was a different thing.
But he,
he,
he knows he liked traces that
to a specific animal that he's packing
out.
Make sense?
Because Sciatica is,
what's Attica is,
is a disc that's bulging,
meaning the disc,
the soft tissue in between the two hard
bones is pushing out and it's pressing
up against the nerve and causes pain
that shoots down your ass and your lower
legs and a lot of people don't even
recognize it as a lower back issue
because maybe their back is not really
that painful,
but the last leg in the ass as painful,
what the fuck is going on here?
I had a similar issue with my neck where
it was pushing on my older nerve and I
was getting this elbow pain and I was
like,
fuck,
this really hurts,
like down my arm and in the back of my
tricep.
And then I started getting numbness in
my fingers and that's when I started
figuring out what was going on.
Then I went to a doctor,
I went to a chiropractor first,
which is a fucking giant mistake.
I spent a year,
but do not believe in chiropractors.
I don't believe in chiropractors at all.
I think it's 98 percent horseshit.
That's what I think.
And um,
I don't know,
but I think chiropractors that are
smart,
they incorporate things that I think are
beneficial,
cold,
laser massage,
a lot of different things.
But I think that manipulation that they
do,
unless you have like some sort of
significant scoliosis or something,
they're attempting to slowly put back
into position.
I think most of the time it's just
popping your neck and it just feels
good.
But I just like in an immediate sense,
I went to a guy that's a very nice guy
and he was trying to tell me that I
didn't have a bulging disc because he
was pushing down on the top of my head
and it didn't hurt.
I'm like,
okay.
So I was listening to him.
I listened to this guy for like a
fucking year.
I had treatment with him and I still
have these neck problems and back
problems.
And then finally I got an MRI and
they're like,
yeah,
you got a bulging disc.
And I remember being angry.
I remember being angry because I was
angry that I was being treated by who is
a professional that really didn't know
what the fuck they were talking about
and they were treating something that
was a significant issue that I was
experiencing a real deterioration of my
function,
pain.
I wasn't able to do Jujitsu correctly.
There was a lot of a lot of problems
that I was dealing with.
I was like,
well,
what the fuck is this?
Like how to?
And then I started talking to doctors
about it and when you have a bulging
disc man,
they want to cut you open like like
European,
Jada,
and you got to golden silence.
That's a thing that my bros talking
about is the procedure.
He's very nervous about a procedure that
he could or could not do well for some
people it's not a bad move depending on
whether or not your brother's willing to
do all the different things that can,
but he's got a lot of atrophy already,
which is a real bad thing is noticeable.
Yeah.
That's not good because that shit
doesn't grow back.
Yeah.
Bas rutten has it real bad boss route
and former UFC heavyweight champion.
He fucked his neck up and went through a
bunch of different treatments and then
eventually wound up getting fused.
He's got a,
uh,
I believe two discs in,
maybe more in his neck fused together
where he doesn't have any disc tissue.
They just screw the bones and together
and remove the disc tissue and stabilize
the area,
but his right arm is significantly
smaller than his left arm to the point
where he calls it baby arm and this is a
former UFC heavyweight champion of the
world.
And what's ironic is that Sullivan came
from fighting,
but the last thing came from doing a
stunt on sons of anarchy.
He was a,
in some sort of a fight believer,
sons of anarchy,
some sort of a fight scene where they
were doing some things and some guy was
supposed to like throw them on the
ground.
He landed on his head.
So all of that actual flight.
And then you get fucked up,
pretend fight.
And it's bad man.
I mean,
he's slowly starting to come back,
but I've known boss to have this issue
for a we.
We worked together on a movie before my
seven year old daughter was born and he
had the issue then and so for seven
years and still now does.
It still does.
It's coming back slowly.
But when I'm talking about is like,
I think there's some that like the way
that your nerves regenerate is extremely
slow.
They can deteriorate quickly.
Like the attribute can happen pretty
quick,
but the way it regenerates is extremely
slow.
So they say once you have atrophy,
you're fucked.
Like you gotta act on it right away.
That's the thing they told me when I had
lyme disease.
Is that
a thing that fucks you up as the nerve
damage?
Yeah,
and then people peep.
Allow people to think that they always
have it.
Put the like you had a thing.
It's treated,
it's gone,
but it will live with you for so long
because of the damage to your nerves.
It's just so slow to recuperate.
I talked to a doctor about lyme disease
and he said,
it's not just a lyme disease you're
dealing with said lyme disease is this
overall term.
He said,
you can get a tick that has 100
pathogens in it.
When you look at that list of Shit,
it gets scary.
It's scary as fuck,
and they connected it to more jealous.
Do you know what more gentleman's is?
No challenge challenges a disease that a
lot of times they think of psychosomatic
because there is some sort of a neuro
toxicity involved in lyme disease and
all these people that have more jealous,
a almost without a doubt have lyme
disease as well and wouldn't.
More gallons is is they have they start
itching it themselves and they think
they have fibers growing out of their
body and they start hallucinating.
Well,
most most of the time it's treated as a
psychosomatic disorder.
Like they'll get carpet fibers in their
body and they'll claim these carpet
fibers are coming out of their body and
growing others jail.
But I talked to this doctor who was the
only loose,
had person that's sort of explained it
to me because he's a doctor and he has
more jealous and he was saying,
and he also has lyme disease and he says
to a person,
they all have lyme disease,
uh,
that he's encountered at least,
but he was saying that he was looking at
himself in the mirror and he saw
something moving across the surface of
his eye and he knew it was a
hallucination and he realized it was a
hallucination as a doctor,
as an educated man and medicine and
still was seeing it and was freaking
out.
And then that.
And then he realized,
oh,
there's some sort of an extreme
neurotoxic effect that this stuff has,
you know.
And then he started doing like some
pretty deep investigation into what
constitutes lyme disease.
And he's like,
well,
it's not like,
you know,
you have herpes,
you know.
No,
it's not like that.
Because like you get bit by something,
you got a bunch of shit in that cocktail
of whatever that disgusting tickets
carrying around.
And it's variable.
You know,
you might get it from one part of the
east coast and it has,
you know,
50 things,
you might get it from another as 13
things and,
but he's saying with the people that
have more gentleman's what he believes
is they're suffering from hallucinations
brought on by lyme disease.
That's,
that's the thing about lying that I
found was,
um,
about medicine and about people and
about mysterious diseases.
Like I quit doing it now,
but I would get in arguments with people
were like,
I was trying to deal with it and finding
out about it.
And people were telling me like,
here's what's happening to me.
I'm like,
well no,
I was told that's not how it works
because there's so much a scent that you
bring up earlier about a doctor or
chiropractor telling you the wrong
thing.
There's so much,
um,
subject,
subjectivity in the fucking medical
world that it's like on one hand all
these people were sort of going through
this,
uh,
this regimen,
this educational regimen,
which is,
you know,
it's like there's like government
oversight.
There's certain criteria you need to
meet,
right?
Things needed to pass.
And you think you already sort of like
have this unifying effect,
but people come out on the other end who
have gone through kind of the same
educational system telling you fuck with
wildly different shit.
Yeah,
wildly different shit about the problems
where one guy like you could walk in,
one guy's going to do a surgery and the
next day I was like,
oh,
no way.
Yeah.
Who was been in his balls?
Who was it wasn't Steevo right?
Who the fuck was it?
Said that San Antonio.
I think Andrew Santina.
He was telling me that he went to.
He had assistant his balls and he
thought he had bowel cancer,
went to a doctor and one doctor told him
that he has excess come stored up in his
balls,
sperm that stored up in his balls and
that's what's causing this not.
He went home to his wife and said he
went to another doctor now he wasn't
married at the time.
He was young man that went head.
And the second doctor said,
who the fuck was that doctor?
That guy should lose his ability to
practice like you don't get calm stored
up in your balls and it makes some sort
of a not like he's saying,
who told you this?
A fucking real practicing doctor told
him that.
Yeah.
I used to go into it when I was younger.
I'd go into it thinking it was like
going to those like going to get an oil
change,
right?
You could have 20 people in there.
All good.
Change your oil like the same way.
What we do is we drain it and put new
shit in.
I'm like,
great,
now I realize that Mr. fucking roll the
dice man.
Roll the dice and here's what you're
going to try to mitigate that by doing
some research,
but it really is like,
I'll have the guys going to tell him
he's not gonna.
Tell me the same thing there guys.
Gonna tell me.
The big thing
comes to health and this is one of the
things that I have a big problem with
when it comes to anything dealing with
the back is preventative maintenance is
like one of the most important things
for back health.
We're sitting in desks all day and most
people are not sitting up straight.
They're not sitting a book.
Good thing.
It's like one of those balls,
those Jim balls was big balance balls.
Those are great to sit on because they
forced you to kind of stabilize yourself
and use your core muscles or some sort
of an ergonomic chair forcing you to
stabilize,
but doctor's not telling you,
hey man,
you got to take a yoga class a couple
days a week.
You got to do something to straighten
out your posture.
You got to do something to make sure
that your spine is strong enough to be
caring about.
You can't slump forward because you're
putting undue pressure on these
different portions of your back.
Is that a significant amount of doctors
are just not fucking telling you that.
They were like,
Oh yeah,
your disc is bulging.
We're going to have to do a disectomy.
No worries.
It's outpatient is outpatient procedure,
but then not telling you is they're.
They're chopping off of a chunk of this
finite material.
There's a small amount of material that
separates your discs and when they talk
about,
oh,
I have disc degenerative disorder,
it's a disease,
my disc,
no stop.
It's not a disease.
What's going on is you're compressing
your body through weightlifting through
extreme exercise.
Your body is slowly getting smushed
down.
You're not allowing it to recover.
You're not stretching it out.
You're not strengthening all those core
muscles.
You're not giving it some time off.
You're probably engaging the same
damaging activity over and over again
and toughing it out.
If there's one thing you should never
fucking tough out,
it's a back issue.
Anytime there's something going on with
your back,
don't tough it out.
Don't try to work through it,
just don't because you're going to fuck
it up worse,
and then it's going to get to a point
where it just does not recover it and
then you're going to have to get
surgery.
This is all.
This is making me super self conscious
about how I like Larry King,
man
so bad,
a chair and I used to much more.
I do try to sit up as much as I can now,
but these chairs have been here.
I went away for a couple of days trying
to sit straighter,
staring at you,
sitting all nice for three hours.
I try,
man.
I didn't always used to be good at it.
I used to slump quite a bit before I had
back issues.
I got to catch up.
These chairs are called a capisce co
chairs there from Ergo depot.
Um,
you can get an Ergo depot.com and get
these fucking things.
So the shit they're,
they're comfortable enough to sit in to.
I've been on,
some of them were your knees slide in
and there's a pad against your Shin?
Those are kind of gross.
These seem much more like an actual
chair,
but they're super comfortable.
What's it called?
It's called a cup hisco.
So that's a good drink.
I know.
Ergo depot.com.
No,
they didn't pay me to say that,
but these things are the shit backs.
Man's vacs or the one thing like when
people have these heavy packouts and
everybody likes to pride themselves on
150 pounds.
Seven miles.
You don't.
I'm telling.
I'm prone to saying those kinds of
things.
I tell everybody packed,
take 75 and do it twice.
Police and even,
that's a lot,
man.
I have this new thing that I go.
Why do people,
why do they like to talk about?
Because you want to be bad asses.
Yeah.
But you'd never be like,
yeah man.
I jumped out from the truck and just
joke the way right in time will tell
their friends to,
you know Mike,
he packed out to elk quarters on his
back.
Dude,
Dude's a fucking savage and I got
[inaudible] probably going to have no
legs.
Dude's a fucking dumb ass.
Fucking legs are gonna stop working.
Probably like got a massive bulge in his
back.
No,
I,
I'm guilty because I,
uh,
I traffic in those stories and when I
hear those stories I'm like,
right on,
Bro.
Well,
you know how hard it is.
That's why when you've done a pack out,
a real packout,
you know,
uh,
hardest,
I remember when we shot that mule deer
right there in Montana and we only
walked like,
what was it,
two miles maybe,
and we had the meat split up between
like three of us,
so it was probably only like 50 pounds
on everybody's back.
And I was like,
Holy Shit.
Once he finally got to camp two miles
pretty,
pretty flat.
It wasn't that hilly.
Yeah.
If you're not accustomed to this
exhausting.
Yeah.
So if you're not accustomed to getting
bit by bs six times a day,
it's overwhelming.
So I should tell people that,
uh,
the outdoorsman,
I know a company that you liked their
products as well.
They make an atlas trainer now it's a
salary.
You were messing with that fucking
grind.
You gotta wait,
you put out?
Yeah.
It's like an Olympic late slides in post
and it clamps down.
I thought maybe you rig that up
yourself.
No,
no,
they're selling it now.
It's their thing.
I saw that.
Yeah,
that I thought it was like you.
I thought you'd gone down to the
hardware store.
I knew I knew the frame,
but I didn't recognize the.
I know guys do it,
but usually they use sand bags,
put sand bags in their backpack and get
used to.
It makes a big difference and it's an
incredible work and it doesn't shift.
Doesn't shift at all and you really lock
it in place.
You don't have the risk of like
tweaking,
right?
Like it's strength,
but it's not.
Because when you shits wiggling around,
then it like,
I don't know if it doesn't really make
you stronger,
it makes you more inclined to like,
fuck something up and yeah.
To twist funny.
Yeah.
No,
I agree.
You know,
but I just think poor people just please
just,
just exercise your back,
treat it like it's like brushing your
teeth just to take yoga.
You don't have to take anything.
Just get some youtube videos.
They're free,
they're available everywhere.
Just do something to strengthen your
back.
You will prevent.
Most people don't want to listen to this
and they're not going to do it because
people are lazy as fuck.
But you will prevent a host of issues
that people have just by exercising your
back.
Simple stuff there.
There's the atlas trainer right there.
Yeah.
You could do chin ups on if you're a
fucking savage.
Like this guy is an animal.
But um,
yeah,
you could carry up to 90 pounds that
thing.
So it will take to a pedophile,
take 100 pound plates to under just
don't know if the plates designed for
it.
If the pack or others designed for it,
that's a good idea to do.
Pull up that sumbitch on.
Yeah.
I use a weight belt,
put like a belt and a hang a kettle bell
in between my legs.
I put a 50 pound Kettlebell on a chain
and I do chin ups like that.
Really?
That's hanging where it's right between
my legs,
like it's a big leather straps fall
across your legs in between the straps
on my back or my hip like this.
And then there's like a chain in between
my legs and the Kettlebell hangs in
which we might legs.
But it's not getting your scroll at all.
No,
no,
no.
Swinging low swing.
It got gotta,
make sure your legs are separated so
it's not cracking against your knees,
but you know when you're doing chin ups,
it's just hanging there.
No Shit.
Yeah,
they say that that's the best way to get
more reps in with your chin ups is not
to try like 1920.
The actually the best way is do less,
but with heavy weights do like a,
you know,
put a weight vest on or hang a 70 pound
kettle bell in between your legs.
Just that three or four.
But again,
you run the risk of injury because it's
your.
Maybe that's why I've never done it.
Yeah,
you're putting a lot.
You've got to build yourself up to it,
you know,
that's what also one of the big things
that happens to people when they start
to exercise and they just try to go too
hard too.
They go to full balls is a,
as I remember,
uh,
various times not running for long time
and they'd be like,
yeah,
I'm going to start running and growing a
five mile run.
I've been running now for just a little
over a month.
I got a friend who's a runner and I'm
like,
he,
he's a hobbyist but runs marathons and
he never did before,
but he was saying
he was talking,
he wrote,
he's a writer,
so he's been writing about that a little
bit and he was saying he just wrote a
piece about
you don't run to get in shape.
You gotta get shaped.
Then start running.
Yeah,
that's a good idea to smart.
We say there's some steps.
There's some.
If you're just like a Slob,
right?
There's some things you need to get
taken care of before you embark on that
smart ground.
There's groundwork that needs to be done
to get ready for the run.
I talked to.
I don't like to ever discourage people
from doing Jujitsu,
but I talked to a buddy of mine who just
did Jujitsu from.
He's 43 years of slaving behavior,
no exercise whatsoever other than the
occasional pickup basketball game for
like seven years,
and then he started doing Jujitsu and
immediately his body's falling apart.
I'm like,
okay,
I know this is going to be hard for you
to do,
but if you really want to do it,
you got to get in shape first.
Just start out with grassland and got
into our Rathlin.
Steven Rinella.
You got to get out of here at 3:15.
Listen man,
you got one of the best podcasts in the
world.
It's fucking awesome.
I love listening to it.
I'm so happy you do it and I think
you've got the best hunting show ever,
so I owe the podcast,
all of you,
Joe Rogan.
Well,
listen,
man,
hanging out with you.
Look so easy for you.
You,
you have so many great stories and you
such a good talker.
I was like,
how the fuck does this guy not have a
podcast?
I'm glad you steered me in that
direction.
Thanks for the plug.
I'm glad you're still doing it.
It's called a mediator podcast.
It's available everywhere and a mediator
is available on Netflix and uh,
right now it's only.
How many seasons do you get?
Five and six seasons.
Five and six.
Five there will will have more.
We've got more.
We got a dozen episodes that are new
that we're going to be released,
so just stay tuned and then I,
you know,
months ago,
back in a couple months ago,
if you go to my instagram,
Steven Rinella,
you'll scroll back and find a bunch of
pictures from.
You'll find a bunch of Guyana photos.
Yeah,
amazing stuff from Guyana,
but we never even talked about.
We did talk about that.
You'll find the pictures.
Good Times.
Thanks for doing this,
man.